Muy buenas tardes a todos. Aquí empezamos la tercera sesión del curso de
tréneco agrémico a ver si todo el mundo me escucha bien porque ahora mismo entre
tanto monitor no sé dónde tengo yo la transmisión o sea no veo lo que se está
viendo a ver pantalla y por qué no veo yo sí pero no sé por qué donde tengo la
no sé dónde está la verdad la ventana de la ventana del directo yo tengo una
ventanita que no sé dónde está bueno pues nada a mirar aquí se ha quedado
aquí debajo para después de un poquito de gemitada para empezar porque esto ya
se estaba grabando procedo a iniciar a iniciar la clase voy a compartir el
monitor porque si no pues mal vamos hoy hasta compartir el monitor no no es que
el presentador no sé quién es presentador pero no soy el presentador
me nombro me nombro presentador ya está no me había nombrado presentador si si
si vale pues nada ya me he nombrado presentador y ahora ya puedo presentar
es eso por eso no veía yo la otra ventanita porque claro no no era
presentador venga ahora sí todo normal bien la semana pasada introdujimos
introdujimos el bueno los canales de don chan y hoy antes de proseguir con ello
aunque va relacionado relacionado pero quiero enseñaros quiero enseñaros una
cosa que ha pasado esta semana porque bueno es lo que tiene la gracias del
curso es eso no puedes ir siguiendo la actualidad a ver si tenía bueno lo tengo
aquí documentado pero creo que tenía los países como tal preparado bien
durante la teoría aquellos que lo hayáis podido ver en algún momento del
curso comenté que las bases de datos se podían cargar el diario incluso recuerdo
que alguien me preguntó al respecto de por qué usábamos por ejemplo en un
gráfico 500 minutos o 1.440 minutos que al final es el diario un día un día son
enteros 24 horas son 1.440 minutos y el que eso equivale a poner una vela diaria
de hecho ahí estáis viendo de izquierda a derecha el nasdaq en 1.440 minutos en
medio el nasdaq en diario que lógicamente es muy muy parecido visualmente es casi
casi igual pero no es exactamente igual ahora lo veréis y a la derecha está en
cinco minutos de acuerdo sin mayor importancia vale entonces hoy esta
semana ha ocurrido ha ocurrido bueno estamos ya sabéis o no sabéis os lo
digo en temporada de publicación de resultados y cuando hay publicación de
resultados en aquellos que se dan al cierre cuando hay grandes creo que fue
bueno mira pero es fácil porque es muy muy claro día 2 el día 2 el día 2 al
cierre esto es no día 2 al cierre no fue no no no día 2 no pero el día 1 el día 1
el día 1 el día gordo fue el día el día 1 estos días cada día hay
jueves el jueves al cierre publicó apple meta y no sé si amazon también creo que
fue publicaban tres metas seguro fue la que pegó una subida estratosférica a
los logos si queréis os la os la enseño pero pero esto pasó al cierre y el cierre
cuando es al cierre normalmente publican nada más cerrar algunas de ellas es
15 con lo cual el mercado el contado acaba de acaba de cerrar y está podemos
decir el subasta y el futuro todavía larga hasta hasta el cuarto y ahí es
donde se provoca se provoca se se hace el cierre oficial lo que llevamos el
set el que es el cierre oficial esto a ver cómo os lo puedo yo enseñar más o
menos bien a bueno es fácil mira lo que voy a hacer es cambiar de monitor la
compartir un momento y acabo más fácil no porque para eso puedo cambiarlo
efectivamente cambio al 2 también al 2 ahí está genial genial genial de
cambios vale entonces aquí lo tenía documentado porque lo documenté las
pantallas aunque ahora os lo enseñaré también el gráfico en situ para verlo
no porque este es un poco la la gran diferencia que hubo es que este día
pero yo creo que aquellos que es más atentos bueno lo enseño que era bueno
lo enseño que era bueno si os fijáis aquí no bueno veis a la izquierda veis el
gráfico de la izquierda que es el diario y a la derecha veis el 1440
minutos la mayoría de velas la mayoría de velas cuando no hay resultados cuando
no hay resultados son iguales pero cuando hay resultados la resultados la
cosa se puede complicar muy mucho y provocar diferencias absolutamente
bestiales la bestial aquí muy clara es esta este es el mismo día es el mismo
día ahora luego en tres se nos enseñó los puntos y todo esta línea blanca que
veis esta línea blanca que veis de acuerdo que pone 17 436 con 75 es ahí
que está pintada de los dos eso es el set el vale es el precio oficial donde
vemos un precio oficial lo veis aquí es el precio oficial que publica el mercado
eso es un precio de liquidación del futuro si tú tienes un vehículo un
fondo o tu cuenta y haces un martu market ese es el precio de liquidación ese día
todos los fondos liquidaron el nasdaq ese precio vale a 17 436 con 75 pero y es
el precio al que cerró la barra diaria diaria pero no es el precio que cotizo
intradía de acuerdo es decir si tú no lo seguías intradía ya os lo mostraré
realmente salió como un misil para arriba de tal manera que hay cinco estaba ya
muy lejos de ahí 5 a las 15 5 minutos después estaba lo mejor 200 puntos por
encima entonces si tú operas en diario si tú estás usando un sistema en el
gráfico diario a ti no te interesa el precio de liquidación oficial te
interesa el precio a que ha habido intercambios en el mercado otra cosa es
que tú me digas no yo quiero parar la operativa a las 10 vale bueno pues bien
entonces sí si por algún motivo tú configuras el horario hasta las 10 pues
será igual pero recordar que al menos entre este hecho y esto sí que es más
bien cosa de cada plataforma la base intradiaria deja cambiar la
configuración horaria es decir yo puedo elegir la sesión que quiera y puedo
operar cargar los datos en aquel periodo que yo quiera pero la diaria no la el
gráfico diario no permite modificar la sesión es toda ella regular vale y esa
la base diaria recoge en el caso de los futuros el precio de liquidación
oficial y por eso veis ahí esa enorme enorme diferencia
enorme diferencia ahora volvemos a tres sesiones y lo podemos mover los
gráficos y os lo os lo muestro vale lo que pasó en la intradiaria está
centradiaria parada hasta ese día ahí está el set el también es esa línea
blanca esa línea blanca que habéis punteada se verá aquí todo esto es la
línea blanca se ve más o menos se verá esa línea blanca 14 mil perdón 14 17
mil 436 con 75 ese es el precio de liquidación oficial que más o menos
aunque tampoco exacto es el precio que cierra a las 3 de las 3 cerró a 17 4
40 poquito por encima más o menos lógicamente y sobre todo cuando el
resultado pues se parece mucho a veces puede ser hasta el mismo es el precio que
hay es ahora entre las 10 las 15 vale ese es el precio que hay pero aquí
fijaros que hay 5 sí que ya reacciona pero poco hubo que salieron ahí en ese
momento pero fijaros ya la de y 10 a las 3 y 10 que es las 10 y 10 nuestras el
precio ya estaba en 518 se decía casi había subido 100 puntos y de tal manera
que a y a las 4 que es a las 11 que es cuando hace la parada el globex algo
antiguamente aunque es verdad que ahora ya esto ya se ha cambiado pero hay cuarto
es donde suele haber volumen normalmente tres y cuarto porque antes
paraba y cuarto si el cuarto había como una especie de parada y el futuro
cerraba y hay cuarto y volvía a abrir ahora no cierra iba continuo hasta las
11 y para de 11 a 12 ser única la única hora que para el globex pero en
definitiva como veis cuando hay resultados sobre todo que puede pasar
cualquier día cambia totalmente entonces a mí ya digo si yo quiero operar si yo
quiero operar hasta las 10 para replicar al contado puedo hacerlo pero
aún así es recomendable que lo hagas con la base intradiaria porque porque tú
reflejarás en el gráfico lo que efectivamente ha pasado en el mercado a
nivel de oferta de demanda es decir estas velas que estás viendo ahora
intradiarias que son de 5 minutos se han construido mediante la compra y venta en
este caso contratos o lo que sea acciones entre los participantes del
mercado y han ido construyendo el gráfico de acuerdo cada 5 minutos vale
entonces ese precio oficial que veis además se produce después de no se
produce al instante en el momento este gráfico cambia y además esto es bueno
pero un punto de curiosidad no lo ves porque esto a las 10 no cerro ahí es
decir estaba abierto y era igual que este a las 11 no no os puedo decir ahora
porque no me acuerdo a que hora exactamente sale el setel pero seguro
que a las 11 no había salido es decir a las 11 la vela era igual era igual a
esta de acuerdo pero entonces el mercado liquida y aparece el setel y la vela
cambia entonces claro imaginaos que tú estabas ahí con un sistema operando en
tiempo real había comprado porque se va para arriba y luego de pronto te
aparece más abajo y al día siguiente aparece no comprado porque porque claro
ha quitado 200 puntos es que quita en este caso más de 200 puntos
vale bien pues este es el motivo por el que si operamos con sistemas al menos
entre ese eso o todo aquel vendedor de datos que en la base diaria refleja el
precio de liquidación oficial del futuro vale en este caso es mejor
construir la vela diaria con la intradiaria que es lo que hace este de
la izquierda que es de 1440 minutos de acuerdo ese simplemente recoge todo el
día pero lo construye con la intradiaria por lo tanto no refleja el
cierre oficial vale y aquí el futuro cerro a lo al precio que le tocara al
precio que realmente cerró la misma de cinco minutos de hecho bueno si lo
ponemos ahí hasta ese día está no la pared el 5
si está el 5 no no no espérate vamos a poner el mismo el jueves y así lo vais
a ver todavía más todavía más claro está todo cerrado antes así lo veis muy
claro es la última vez la última vela del día pero es la la enorme diferencia
fijaros en la línea blanca que es la es un poco la que la que la que marca el
setel la enorme diferencia entre una y la otra entonces la de la derecha que es
de cinco minutos y la de la izquierda que es en en diario pero construida con la
intradiaria es decir de 1440 minutos cierra al mismo precio que esa 17 mil
628 es decir casi casi 200 puntos por encima casi 200 puntos por encima vale
entonces esto esto es la manera de proceder cuando queremos operar
sistemas diarios al menos entre session o al menos con aquellos proveedores de
datos como os digo que en la base de datos diaria reflejen el cierre oficial
el setel que en este caso pues ya digo era era bastante más abajo de esta
raya porque ese dato no se conoce en tiempo real queda claro se conoce a
posterioridad porque es un precio de liquidación que calcula el mercado por
unos x criterios que ahora no vienen a cuento y que lógicamente tienen que ver
con el precio a las 10 vale porque lo mismo pasa con el contado es decir el
contado el tf que replica cerró más o menos al equivalente de ese precio ese
17 4 36 75 aproximadamente pero también tuvo su liquidación pero líquido
parecido a ese no recogió la subida de facebook que pegó un subidón de más
del 15 por ciento si no recuerdo mal y se llevó al nasdaq para arriba como como
un cuento entonces esto durante las práticas durante la teoría recuerdo que
había salido en algún en algún momento y pues esta esta semana ha sido tan
tan claro porque normalmente no hay tanta diferencia de acuerdo normalmente
no hay tanta si veis hay otras velas también distintas aquí porque claro
es lo que os digo estamos en temporada de resultados de publicación de resultados
y pues bueno cuando pasa esto es habitual ves aquí ves otra hay
bastante diferencia pero luego ya pues el resto como veis son parecidas deben de
ser bastante parecidas pero estas dos tres semanas es donde hay más cambios es
donde hay más cambios y por esto que os comento por esto que os comento de los
resultados este día fue bestial y me lo guardé lo dejé ahí documentado un poco
para poderos lo poderos enseñar porque creo que era interesante no
entiendo que esto estará claro pero bueno si alguna
alguna una pues ya vais ya vas atendiendo la tu alberto verdad recordar
que podéis preguntar aquí recordar también los que vais llegando nuevos que
sé que el ritmo pues cada uno un poco lleva el suyo gente que se conecta al
directo gente que no gente que a lo mejor hace la primera clase hoy hay un poco de
todo pues recordar que la vez podéis escribir las preguntas bueno aquí
podéis preguntar directamente en la plataforma alberto está ahí pendiente y
luego también está el disco recordaros que el disco podéis ahí para hacer
vuestras preguntas por cierto los que queráis seguir la temporada de
resultados publicamos siempre en twitter esta semana hace un rato de hecho hemos
publicado los de los de esta semana por lo que es de una web que está muy bien
guueles titulizón y sencillamente lo returneamos pero bueno pues ya ahí
nuestra en nuestro twitter los podéis podéis ver en una imagen además muy
muy chola
lo puedo enseñar porque está en el disco acaba de poner twitter en el disco esta
es la esta es la imagen de esta esta semana que empieza y ahí ves lo que
publica esta semana que siempre la temporada se alarga todavía bastante más
pero ya las grandes tecnológicas ya ya publicaron la pasada ese día
justamente fue el día pero bueno el por ejemplo antes del mercado que no lo he
mirado la verdad como ha visto ha publicado mcdonalds
publicado el disney también el miércoles siempre hay empresas pepsi el
viernes siempre hay empresas grandes muchísimas pero ya digo las grandes
tecnológicas que yo diría que ya han publicado todas alberto amazona
publicado apple facebook google de las más grandes han publicado todas ahora
se ha publicado en vídeo por ejemplo mucho publicó netflix
puede que falte puede que falte que falten y para acabar esto recordar el
1440 minutos es una manera fácil de estar seguro que es la diaria pero por
ejemplo en la sesión regular es un 500 en la americana son 500 minutos al final
es igual si pones 1440 no va a cargar más recordar poner os recomiendo poner
que por formar el building elegir sesionados que eso empieza a construir la
la barra cuando empieza la sesión y es igual a qué hora empieza la sesión en
el momento que empieza la sesión empieza a contar la barra de 5 minutos de
30 de lo que sea o de 1000 minutos en este caso 1440 y lo otro que se decía
aquí yo puedo cambiar la sesión en la intradiaria puedo usar una custom en
cambio en la diaria no es otro motivo también para usar la intradiaria porque
yo puedo configurar la sesión como quiera y hay muchos motivos por la que
puedo querer cambiar la sesión vale no en algún momento del curso pues sí que
lo veremos porque cuando hagamos sistema centralía pues aparecerá casi sin
querer este problema pero uno de los motivos puede ser para cerrar antes del
cierre de la sesión vale si yo quiero cerrar en un sistema intradiario quiero
cerrar al cierre de la sesión uno de los trucos pues puede ser cambiar la
sesión a un minuto menos ya lo veremos cuando hagamos intervías vale pero pero
lo introduzco porque es lo que vamos a ir haciendo todo el curso a medida que
salen las cosas o parecen poder comentar entonces solo en la intradiaria yo puedo
modificar la sesión y puedo hacer lo que quiera exactamente lo que quiera vale
pues ya está y hecho esto vamos a seguir
vamos a seguir vamos a empezar a trabajar el doncha de acuerdo a ver dónde donde
nos lleva hoy el tema y veremos que depende de donde nos lleve pues haremos
una cosa u otra el que viene de acuerdo he empezado porque he empezado por este
porque es un sistema que poco más o menos aquellos que claro aquel que no
ha hecho trading nunca pues no lo he oído hablar pero aquel que haya hecho trading o
que ya lleve un tiempo del mercado es bastante probable que haya oído hablar de
los canales de los indicador bastante unos canales bastante bastante
conocidos durante el curso bueno aquel que no haya oído hablar pues ha oído
hablar en el curso porque en el curso ya en la parte de historia del trading
agonímico aquel que no lo haya hecho recomiendo hacer la curiosidad que está
al principio bueno al principio exacto pero bastante al principio hablamos de
los canales de doncha ni que doncha pues fue uno de los primeros que operó
sistemáticamente y demás no no no automáticamente al uso porque no se
podía pero como ahora pero pero si en el concepto sistemático de ese rigor de
una estrategia muy definida etcétera y diversificando en cientos con voltis y
demás y él usaba pues pues 20 se ha popularizado que usaba 20
20 periodos 20 días que era la regla de las cuatro semanas lo hemos traducido 20
días pero las cuatro semanas operaba bastante de medio largo plazo y el
operaba pues en semanal y luego también de ahí nació el sistema de las tortugas
tengo tengo estos lo pondré luego en el disco porque los podría subir aquí a
bueno mira los voy a subir aquí los voy a subir aquí también los pondré en el
disco también los pondré en el disco pero los voy a subir aquí unos
documentos ahora cuando se van subiendo poco a poco en algún sitio de la
plataforma debes tener unos un sitio que pone ahí documentos a ver si lo si lo
veis yo lo subo ahí tres documentos que he bajado de estos comodities nosotros
estamos suscritos a estos comodities y he hecho un ejercicio bastante curioso de
buscar buscar don chan simplemente hecho esto y me han salido 58 referencias
he cogido tres de las más nuevas para enseñar y además está muy bien ahora os
los enseño pero es que si buscáis el otro día buscáis canales de don chan
pues sale un montón de artículos es algo bastante bastante común pero bueno
por buscar una revista de trading buena no he hecho eso y así he pensado que
os los doy también y así pues mira tenéis esos artículos de una muy buena revista
que pues os recomiendo pero que
bueno que aquel que no creo que no es necesario que os suscribáis es como
todo es interesante suscribirse pero cada uno quiere hacer lo que lo haga lo
veis no lo ve los documentos bueno ahora se está subiendo el tercero se ve por ahí bien
es que no como una pestañita no se ve perfecto vale vale perfecto perfecto es
que claro eso como yo lo veo como como administrador digamos pues no sé si lo
veis exactamente igual entonces esta era la lauda entonces ahí le dais al pdf y
lo podéis lo podéis bajar y demás son tres artículos ya digo los he bajado de
esto gran commodities que lo llama la atención de momento sobre el 2 podría
haberle llamado uno porque si va a empezar por él no ha llamado uno pero
bueno como lo he bajado así porque en apariencia en apariencia son las
originales de don chan al menos así lo así lo explica yo la verdad que no las
había encontrado así como originales porque no existe un libro como tal de
don chan y demás pero sí que había leído que lo había publicado en algún
diario que lo ha extraído ahí y bueno aquí están lo que en apariencia que
repito es el don chan 2 lo tenéis ahí son las reglas originales siempre
interesante y diría que ha sido obligado y recomendable ver las notas
siempre que uséis cualquier indicador se los recomendado en general cualquier
ir al autor original porque veréis que es frecuente que la propia la propia
comunidad pues ha ido modificando a veces las cosas o ignorado ciertas partes
de un de una regla o del indicador o la filosofía del autor lo que el autor
pretendía al diseñarlo que siempre es interesante hacer esta práctica pero
bueno que términos generales en términos generales ya lo sabéis lo que
haces es marcar un canal de precios que en su ruptura pues se incorpora al
mercado como indicado como indicador de inicio de tendencia de acuerdo
lógicamente si ya vieron aquellos activos más tendenciales en aquellos
períodos más más tendenciales yo es un indicador que os recomiendo que os
recomiendo para marcar pero en caso de usarlo interdiariamente que no ahora
pero sí que más adelante trataremos también de hacer alguno ahí sí que es
más complicado hacerlo en tendencia pura es más complicado en algún activo puede
puede conseguirse pero es más complicado es más complicado
que quiero decir en tendencia pura en la teoría lo comentamos pero si uno busca
tendencia pura debe dejar correr los beneficios eso es lo que hace un
tendencial puro vale y eso implica no tenerte pes si queremos operar si
queremos diversificar bien aunque eso va a implicar va a implicar tener peor
sistema o sea un imaginaros que hablando con los perfiles que ya todas las
clases intentó comentarlo y la teoría sabéis que ha hablado mucho de ello no y
comenté que psicológicamente acordaros aquella práctica psicológica que había
no no sé mira eso se lo podía haber hecho como pregunta no de qué resultados
habían salido en aquellos dos ejercicios psicológicos que os había
que os había salido para hacer estadísticas no la podíamos preguntar
mira la próxima día la preguntaré por curiosidad responder honestamente el
próximo día lo pregunto por por haber si salen los ratios que deben de salir
pero bueno yo que sería poco para medir la versión al riesgo normalmente a
medida que al inicio de la carrera trader o incluso no hace falta el inicio
incluso en tres más avanzados se sienten mucho más cómodos con los
sistemas tipo atitendenciales o dicho otra manera sistemas con tasas de
acierto elevadas que es obvio no porque es un poco obvio porque porque al final
en una en un sistema con tasa de acierto elevadas es decir vamos a
suponer que acierta 6 de cada 10 operaciones pues son psicológicamente
más llevaderos vale y tenemos un poquito más de las rachas de fallos
consecutivos no son tan largas son sistemas más estables normalmente mejor
no son los que necesariamente más ganan que esto dependerá lógicamente del
activo pero en términos generales pero sí que son más estables más tranquilos y
normalmente no suelen tener grandes operaciones también suelen ser
intradillarios con cierre a final de día de estar incluso poco tiempo en el
mercado vale normalmente normalmente es un poco ese perfil de sistema ese
perfil de sistema y por lo tanto es normal es normal tener al principio o
incluso ya digo no no solo a principio más estrategias tipo antitenencial y más
aún si vamos a litradía porque muchas veces muchos traders noveles también
empiezan por el entradía que no es que esté mal porque es verdad que en el
entradía yo tengo la sensación y también la realidad es la realidad
también si hago bien mi trabajo y creo un buen sistema que puedo controlar
mejor el riesgo puedo decir que en el entradía puedo controlar mejor el riesgo
porque fijaros ahí lo que habéis visto que su vida no de pronto por los
resultados de meta no imaginaros que estabas corto en meta si estabas largo
pero si estabas corto pues imagínate entonces al final lógicamente al ir a
ir swing al ir a buscar tendencia de días yo estoy sujeto a los gaps a lo
que pueda ocurrir entre sesiones vale y en un intradillario puro no por lo tanto
sólo eso ya me permite controlar mejor el riesgo por lo tanto es normal que yo
tire por esos sistemas tanto al inicio y sobre todo también por si tengo una
cuenta pequeña porque como voy a poder controlar mejor el riesgo seguramente
puedo tener menos drawdown seguramente podré tener menores necesidades de
capital entonces es habitual no que no esto no quiere decir que sea mejor pero
digo que es habitual que el trader con poco capital y poco experimentado acabe
empezando con sistemas antitenenciales y intradillarios vale bien si tú estás
en esa situación al final y quieres para diversificar de nombre pues me iría
bien un tendencial claro si quieres diversificar de verdad la mejor
diversificación te la va a dar un tendencial puro y eso quiere decir que
no tenga tp vale que deje correr vale y que normalmente vaya a continuo vale que
no vaya entre puede operar en el gráfico contrariario pero tiene que
mantener si hay tendencia en la posición entre sesiones puede hacerse
tendencia intradillaria si puede lo que puede pero no es un tendencial puro
entonces ya sería seguramente tendría ratios ya no tan extremos como un
tendencial más cercano 50 ya ser 40 y pico por ejemplo y ahí sí que es
recomendable tener tp porque porque si yo voy a cerrar a final de día pues es
mejor cerrar con objetivo voy a cerrar igual esto lo comentamos recordar en la
en la teoría entonces aquí hemos planteado un don chat que de entrada lo
hemos planteado en la base diaria el otro día lo pusimos con apel el otro día lo
pusimos con apel vamos a volver apel ahora vale y lo pusimos en el diario ahora
me he pasado al 1440 recuerdo simplemente hecho ese cambio ya por eso
también he introducido el otro y me ha ido muy bien la semana porque para eso
ya no lo había hecho la semana pasada porque quería hacerlo tras explicaros
esto y me ha venido bien esta semana hemos tenido suerte que me ha permitido
poner un ejemplo muy visual a ver lo podía haber hecho con un con cualquier
otro día pero pero este era muy bueno porque claro eran 200 puntos y
visualmente se veía mucho el cambio pero bueno estamos aquí con apel con el
sistema de entrada que planteamos don chat la única cambio es que lo hemos
cargado en el 1440 vamos siguiendo bien abierto no por ahí alumnos y demás si
hay algo importante que explicar me lo comentas y los principios como ya
sabéis los recuerdo que las preguntas las tendremos en general al final pero
hombre si hay algo que realmente es importante para el mensaje no esté
llegando algo pues por supuesto pues trataríamos de tenerlo al final lo que
sea mejor es ir haciendo lo que sea lo que sea vale entonces vamos otra vez a
repasar o a tratar de trabajar este este sistema que ya vimos y si os
recordáis distintos activos vimos que validamos la regla de entrada poniendo
esto ptp igualado no tengo aquí todavía no tengo el código pero sí que ya para
la siguiente clase os lo traeré porque ahora voy a enseñar código y voy a
explicaros el código vale sobre el que tengo desarrollado desde que he
trabajado he trabajado bastante un código con algunas cositas que ya de
hecho sirven para varios esto es habitual poquito se llama lo manías o
prácticas de programación y demás que os voy a ir comentando y sí que sí que
os voy a dar el segundo código en el sentido de que hablado podemos decir
pero no voy a entregar un documento como tal pero lo haremos no os preocupéis
no os preocupéis que lo que lo haremos de acuerdo lo haremos evidentemente
tenéis los tres pdfs que os he pasado que también es un segundo código porque
es el tocha ha explicado pero me refiero a las partes que ahora vais a ir viendo
que yo incorporado al sistema a modo de de posibilidades primero punto 1 el
sistema ahora mismo veréis que tiene muchos muchos inputs esto es habitual en
un sistema un input es todo aquella aquel
parámetro susceptible de ser variado desde fuera del código desde aquí y
también de ser optimizado pero recordar que no todo input debe ser optimizado de
hecho casi siempre es así la mayoría la mayoría de los inputs son de
configuración que llamamos al coro son de configuración y no tienen por qué
tocarse o simplemente como en este caso son instrumentales es decir son de
análisis estamos podemos decir en una fase todavía de evaluación preliminar de
crear nuestra idea de crear nuestro sistema y una manera de hacerlo es
implementar varias posibilidades en el código para mediante la observación
mediante la optimización mediante distintas herramientas yo pueda ir
construyendo la idea partiendo ya de una una idea preconcebida de una ventaja que
sé que existe y que ya he evaluado de manera sencilla pero a partir de ahí la
vamos a ir edificando vamos a ir edificando bien este caso es muy muy muy
importante en la teoría lo comenté varias veces lo voy a reiterar mucho
en los sistemas diarios y más aún semanales éste lo podíamos haber hecho
perfectamente semanal pero no he querido irme a tan extremo de entrada veremos
sistemas semanales pero no quería irme ya tan tan extremo preferido un término
podemos decirme porque es medio porque es verdad que un diario muchas veces
tiene muy poco straight como para realmente permitir algún proceso de
optimización al uso al uso quiero decir para elegir parámetros pero así que yo
puedo realizar optimizaciones instrumentales para tratar de analizar
la información de construir a lo mejor un mapa de construir un perfil de
optimización como vimos con el excel para ver un poco cómo se cómo se cómo va el
sistema por ejemplo en otros en otros parámetros decir yo hablamos por
ejemplo que don chan por defectos 20 no digo me pues yo voy a ver cómo van
otros puedo poner un mano a mano 20 19 18 o puedo pasar al optimizador pasarlo
a excel y analizarlo en una tabla de excel entonces yo optimizado pero no con
la idea de elegir o cambiar los parámetros sino simplemente de analizar
cómo se mueve el sistema entre distintos cambios de parámetro y además lo puedo
hacer en un activo o lo puedo hacer en varios que a partir de diario es más
que recomendable en intradiario también es recomendable pero si diría
recomendables en todos quizá que el diario podemos decir que es más más que
obligado y a partir de diario es obligado y ya en semanal y mensual ultra obligado
ultra ultra obligado es decir casi imposible trabajar con un solo activo un
sistema es decir hay que analizarlo vía cestas de activos porque porque no hay
trades contra más time frame más elevados a time frame pues más
universal es la idea esto lo hemos ido comentar vale entonces aquí veis muchos
muchos inputs ya los los voy a explicar a ver los voy a explicar para que
entendáis un poquito cómo trabajamos cómo trabajamos las ideas primer punto
primer punto como trabajamos una idea lo primero es que llegamos llegamos a la
idea que hemos encontrado en este caso ya os comenté que veremos
muchas y veremos algunas también mediante código no tardaremos en hacer
eso no tardaremos en hacer alguna alguna clase de búsqueda de ideas es decir de
trabajar de trabajar buscadores de ideas a través del código pero muy dirigido
muy dirigido esta es la gran diferencia entre las búsquedas de ideas que vais a
ver con nosotros a los
los buscadores a los buscadores por fuerza bruta es que aquí la búsqueda
está totalmente dirigida es decir está muy cerrada y muy central es decir yo le
marco cuatro o cinco seis cosas a buscar y ya sé elegido yo esas cosas el tema en
la en estas programas el problema es que la búsqueda es tremendamente variable
encima además es también modificando el input además de la idea y es una
sobreutilización de extremadamente sencillas aquí también podemos hacerla
pero es más difícil porque yo ya parto de una de una idea de acuerdo parto de
un principio de un concepto este es siempre lo importante y necesaria
vale me voy a construir esto así para ir explicándolo viendo un poquito el
sistema al lado la regla de entrada vamos por
vamos por partes la letra se le viene alberto de disilengüe toqué si no
creo que si no la puedo hacer la puedo hacer más grande la letra de disilengüe
se le viene ya la tengo un poco más grande ya la tengo un poco más grande
pero pero la verdad que el que el este este interfaz el co2 meeting genera unos
vídeos de una calidad absoluta y que lo veis bien también en la plataforma es
fantástico bueno hay mucho código no los que no sepa es programar y demás de
verdad no no importa os enseño el código porque ahí voy a explicarlo pero
no no es importante de verdad no es importante no os quedéis con el código
ni ahora me empecéis a bloquear os hoy es que esto que lío yo no sé programar
igual os enseño ahí porque tengo que leerlo en algún sitio entonces ya que lo
voy a leer de memoria no me lo sé lo toqué leyendo entonces
pero no no es de verdad que no es no es importante ahora el código el código
así el código como os he dicho todo el rato en la teoría es una herramienta ni
más porque el ordenador sino no me entiende que no tardará en entenderme
así pero no tardará ya en entenderme así programar esta clase y el arco no
tardaremos pero de momento todavía hay que escribir entonces iré arriba y
abajo porque depende como me interesa vale cuál es el setup el setup de
entrada general del sistema ya lo hemos hablado ahora respecto a la semana
pasada incorporado una pequeña una pequeña variación y ahora os voy a
explicar las dos tres variantes que hay de don chan o cómo interpretar una
ruptura esto ya no se vive para don chan se sirve también para cualquier
ruptura hay un componente de gusto y un componente también de probar de probar
a ver cuál cuál puede ir mejor en cada en cada activo pero hay un componente
bastante de acuerdo cuál es el setup el setup
cuadrado mejor esto en rojo bien aquí ese es el setup de entrada general que
viene a decir que si el cierre de una vela es mayor o igual que el mayor
cierre de las últimas n barras por defecto hemos puesto 20 esto lo marca
el input un input esto lo marca un input hemos llamado per canal
compra en la apertura de la siguiente barra el número de contratos en que
ahora luego hablaremos esto es lo que marca una entrada estándar
una diferencia que he hecho hoy es que he incorporado que porque el otro día lo
dejé con cierres expresamente porque quería quería forzar este debate de
porque es verdad que lo normal o lo más habitual en un canal de don chan es no
usar el cierre para medir el máximo sino usar el cil el máximo esto mira lo vais
a ver muy fácil aquí ahora os lo voy a mirar espérate porque no acabo de caer
que esto a veces se me olvida que esto es para dar una clase entonces las
líneas tienen que verse sérgio las líneas tienen que ver entonces vamos a
ponerlo así para que se vea mejor la línea del canal que sí ahora se ve bien
y también va a enseñar el gráfico otra vez porque lo he vuelto a dejar que no
se ve bien y hay acero sin transferencia mucho mejor este canal que veis arriba
y abajo es el canal de 20 barras por cierto ligo con alguna pregunta que
había habido en el disco de cómo se pintaba esto ahora ahora os lo
pero acabo esa idea es este no pinta los máximos sino pinta o mejor dicho pinta
los máximos de 20 barras pero de los cierres yo puedo pintarlo de lo que
quiera puedo hacerlo del máximo y del mínimo que esto es lo habitual ahora sí
que veréis que es el máximo es el máximo lógicamente hasta la vela en
curso porque si no nunca rompería se entiende si cuento el máximo de la
vela en curso no rompe nunca entonces es el 20 hasta el anterior el 20 hasta el
anterior no se importa que este ahora está hecho con los máximos y con los
mínimos esto es el canal habitual
por una una de las reglas que nosotros más usamos para esto para elegir esto es
que en diario cuando trabajamos la base diaria el cierre lo consideramos bastante
muy importante por lo tanto normalmente y todavía más en acciones todavía más
en acciones o en esa menos lo digo en este no lo he probado lo podemos probar
ahora lo vamos a ver ahora pero creo que va a funcionar mejor o a mí me genera
más confianza mayor seguridad el que los máximos y los mínimos se calculen con
los cierres porque porque el cierre es algo importante por tanto en el sentido
de que es el final de un periodo el mercado abre la sesión acaba a las 10
de la noche hay una larga pausa de horas y vuelve a abrir entonces el cierre hay
mucho operador interdiario que entra y abre o sea que abre y cierra la posición
durante el día y por lo tanto el precio que marca el cierre sí que define muy
bien o define mejor que el máximo o el mínimo la tendencia de fondo de ese
activo esto es especialmente así en aquellos activos que tengan largas
pausas como las acciones me dices hombre en el futuro bueno en el futuro situó la
vela diaria está construida por el caso del globes estas 23 horas que decíamos
ahí seguramente es menos relevante pero si tú vas a operar el futuro en horarios
regular es decir de las tres y media hora española a las 10 o 14 hora española
entonces lo mismo me acuerdo hay muchas horas de pausa por lo tanto el cierre
tiene una especial importancia entonces nosotros en estos casos nos gusta
trabajar con el campo cierre vale más que máximo y mínimo si fuera
interdiario entonces cien por cien el valor a que cierra cualquier vela
interdiaria tiene cero relevante que cierra una vela de cinco minutos cuando
inmediatamente tiene otra importa entre 0 y 0,1 entonces ahí sí que el campo
cierre no dice nada ahí sí que o bien usamos máximos o mínimos o si que hay
que usar un valor centrado usamos típica el price usamos típica el price
que es típica el price típica el price muchas plataformas hasta lo tienen
incorporado como precio es la media entre máximo mínimo y cierre de esos tres es
un precio más centrado más centrado la media entre máximo mínimo y cierre
dividido por tres lógicamente al final es hay más low más close partido por
tres eso es típico entonces como aquí de entrada empezamos a hablar de
por eso los canales los definimos de entrada con el campo cierre por lo que
al código vale este price ahora lo he definido como un input nuevamente lo que
se hacía de configuración porque porque yo rápidamente en el código puedo
cambiar que el canal se calcule bien con el close bien con el high bien con el low
y lo puedo hacer desde aquí también lo podría hacer con típica el price
puedes escribir aquí yo puedo yo puedo hacer esto yo puedo hacer esto yo puedo
hacer esto puedo hacer esto sin ningún tipo de problema
típica directo también va porque es función no sé si no puedes poner una
función que devuelva un precio claro si está que creo que es verdad
me lo estaba llevando por aquí si existe como función me va a dar error
perfecto típica el price porque es una función que ya existe cualquier
cualquier valor que devuelva un precio ahí puedo ponerlo como típica el price
veces lo ponen magenta porque es un oro labro es un es una función que como
veis es hay más low más creo multiplicado por un tercio esto es una
técnica de programación porque es mejor procesado o multiplicar que dividir y
entonces no tiene mayor no tiene mayor relevancia que es lo mismo que dividir
por tres pero como habéis visto lo podéis directamente escribir
pero para eso es un ímpod para yo poder cambiar rápidamente no necesariamente
quiere decir que optimizarlo todo sino que me permita mejor probar cosas de
manera rápida yo quiero le puedo poner h y le pongo l y rápidamente ahora el
canal va con high y con low en vez de con plus y puedo analizar que hace el
sistema ha hecho mal no sé qué ha hecho mal porque no hay salida pero
por qué no puede ser no hay salida a bueno porque le he puesto está trúspera
t está en tu salida en media no sé qué pasa algo tocó en el código sin querer
ahora a bueno porque no tiene salida y se había quedado dentro vale vale vale
ahora tengo un fallo el código que eso podría ser podría ser que tuviera un
fallo en la salida de la media a ver bueno de momento aquí no pero la media
había pensado ponerla con él con el close igualmente sí sí bueno ya irá
saliendo si hay algún fallo ya irá saliendo luego pero no lo veo ahora el
fallo seguimos seguimos explicando un poquito el código el don chan acordaros
el otro día le pusimos un stop simétrico rápido de si no está
compilado pero el razón pero no debería de se queda con la versión
anterior bueno es igual así con el cierre funciona no sé por qué no
funciona bien pero igual se funciona bien pero pero no sé por qué cambia
tanto con el high con el low algo algo se me está escapando ahora mismo no no
veo pero en mayúsculas se me está escapando no veo exactamente por qué
porque se sale con la media con cierres se sale aquí no vuelve a cerrar por la
media en toda la subida parece raro no parece raro que sea tan exigente no como
no eso es el indicador que va a la siguiente vela
pero que se hagas en abril sí sí sí el pero por eso no tengo igual para evitar
eso para evitar eso ya pero lo que dice aurelia ya lo entiendo pero claro sí sí
es compra compra mucho menos así claro compra a molto mucho menos mucho menos
si se lo vamos a dejar como había hecho una invitada en el código
importante a ver qué daba esto se me ha abierto en la otra ventana bueno ahora
tiene que estar monetaria no los números son un poco iguales
los 63 a ver un momento que lo cambio que otra vez
ahora está hay lo que está close seguimos ahora está con close con 20 y
los canales los compite también 20 clothes clothes y aquí 20 saco jai con
low los aquí clothes así ya tenemos todo todo igual perfecto no sé que lo que lo
que lo ponía quien era aureli aureli aureli si si aureli aureli tenías
tenía su razón que está aquí lo decía alguien más creo sí sí sí
obviamente tenías tenías tu razón es la invitada gorda de programación no sé
que lo había sacado de otro doncha que teníamos pero no sé por qué se me había
se me había colado se me había colado y claro en el cierre no se notaba tanto
pero al poner el jaegers aún colaba porque había igual por eso en algunos
compraba porque como tenía igual en algunos compraba pero pero es mejor sacar
el igual y ponerlo en la bala en la referencia de la vela anterior lo
explico lo explico para que no lo haya seguido porque si no se me va se me va
a volver loco de hecho antes lo decía lo explicaba pero en el código no estaba
bien es decir al final tú tienes que referirte a ver dónde está lo de
pintar pero lo veo ahora mismo tengo de pintar aquí
mira vamos a centrarnos en esto vale que cierre es el que marca que cierre es el
que marca que se va por encima este y compra la siguiente de acuerdo entonces
yo tengo que hacer que el sistema que el canal se calcule hasta la anterior sin
incluir la actual porque si incluyó la actual antes lo decía de hecho el cierre
nunca va a ser más que el máximo se incluyó la actual tengo que dejar
calcularlo hasta la anterior y esto antes lo he dicho pero en el código estaba mal
el código no había hecho esa referencia anterior no importa no importa los que
no sepáis programar que ahora mismo da igual ahora ya está bien en el gráfico
hay que referirse hasta la anterior entonces este es en cuanto al set up
básico ahora mismo el sistema como lo hicimos otra vez que bueno creo que
tenía este código ahora os voy a dejar igual que el otro día vale le quito la
salida central ahora os hablare de esa salida ahora os hablare de todas las salidas que he
incorporado vale vamos a evaluar el otro día hicimos esto hicimos esto para ver
poniendo riesgo y profit simétrico lo cual nos va a dar un win-loss parecido
que sólo pueda salir mediante esa herramienta que no pueda salir ni por n
barras ni puede salir por profit por trailing o por ninguno otro sólo
puede salir por ésta vale y esto os comenté que es una manera de igualar el
ratio win-loss aquel que no lo viera recuerdo ver la segunda clase y ver qué
por un viaje de acierto de momento ahora aquí ya vemos que no nos da en esta
configuración vale da pérdidas vamos a buscar un set up que nos de
0 0 5 todavía salta bastante creo que con 0 10 nos daba no ahí está con 0 10
nos da a la gestión monetaria con 0 10 es igual ahora es que prefería que
saliera positivo aquí veréis que tenemos una tasa de acierto por encima
del 50 claramente y un ratio win-loss que debería de estar está un poco por
debajo de 0 81 está un poco por debajo de 1 bueno está bastante por debajo de
claro está por debajo de 1 porque nosotros lo calculamos el porcentaje y
él lo está calculando en monetario es una de las puntos débiles que para mí
tiene tres hecho que multichars no lo tiene el próximo día trataré de
cambiar a multichars para que vayáis viendo las dos las dos fuentes que
nosotros usamos más y ya os comenté pero y por ejemplo veremos esto
aquí se nota mucho ahora
lo voy a dejar estable un número de acciones elevado y le voy a poner que
vaya con estas mil acciones bloqueado y ya está ahora veréis la gestión
monetaria siempre va con 1000 varía por lo tanto tenemos un ratio de 1 45 y
seguimos igual seguimos igual nos hemos quedado no se ha solucionado pensaba que
solucionaría un poco pero no se ha solucionado porque la variación de
precios es muy es muy es muy gigantesca es lo que nos digo depende dónde tiene
las tasas de acierto y de fallos porque los tres y que los tres están todos
alrededor claro por dar que hay gaps y demás pero veis que están alrededor del
10 por ciento el 10 por ciento pero lógicamente en dólares a medida que va
avanzando pues cambia cambia bastante porque depende bastante del precio el
activo estamos hablando ya de estamos dando de lo que tengo cargado 25 años
los cargados 25 años pues claro tenemos compras aquí a céntimos y compras aquí
a 180 dólares entonces el problema de las acciones es muy importante entonces
la diferencia es gigantesca los trade son del orden del 10 por ciento pero el
valor monetario no recuerdo el valor monetario no es del orden del 10 por
ciento es imposible si lo hubiéramos hecho el esto el valor monetario
cualizaría mejor en ese sentido en el sentido de los ratios pero ahora mismo
eso me da igual no me importa simplemente era para que lo para que lo
cualizado a un nivel de riesgo en porcentaje igual o muy parecido y aquí
como tenés eso me lo calcula luego yo en excel lo podría calcular como quisiera
ya lo visteis que lo hicimos y con muchos muchos fitness y demás pero aquí el
ratio me lo calcula pero bueno todo caso ya se ve que es claramente claramente
tiene una verdad y un porcentaje de aciertos bastante bastante elevado es decir el
setup de entrada en sí es es bueno es bueno es es claramente bueno y permite
seguir trabajando con él que es lo que lo que queremos esto como ya os comenté
los suyos verlo en distintos activos podemos verlo aquí en el ex lk o que
ahora me va a tener que cargar un poquito que cargue y mientras volvemos al
código lo tenéis que ver en varios ya lo vimos un poquito más esto no me
reitero porque cambio este que hemos hecho seguramente no seguro que no
afecta al hecho de que sea válida o no en este punto que estamos ahora entonces
yo aquí incorporado una
flexión monetaria es decir una capacidad de mover de mover el lotaje
vale eso recordar que os comenté que sobre todo en aquellos activos que
varían tanto de precio es recomendable para ir adaptando un poquito las
posiciones a los precios porque si no es imposible vale voy ahora mientras
se cargan los datos voy a cambiar ya esto otra vez voy a volver a activar la
fisiotera ahora os enseñaré en el código como lo que vamos y lo desactivamos
esto dejado perfecto sencillamente lo que lo que estoy haciendo ahora es una muy
muy sencilla que es monetaria no no la justo por riesgo no la controlo por
volatilidad simplemente va a nominal es decir que hay una fórmula que repito no
importa pero lo que hace es dividir el total de la cuenta por el 100%
dividir el total de la cuenta lo multiplica por cien que es la exposición
que yo quiero quiere decir que invertir todo mi dinero 100 por cien son mil
dineros de como que mil por cien mil y lo divido por el cierre y de esa manera
invierto una cantidad aproximada aproximadamente invierto aproximadamente
el 100% de mi cuenta de acuerdo pero todo todo el rato lo estoy haciendo todo el
rato estoy invirtiendo el 100% de la cuenta porque eso no es que no es que
quiera hacer eso siempre se nos me menta ahora estoy permitiendo que varíe para
que esta enorme diferencia que habéis visto entre un dólar a 300 dólares pues
se compense porque evidentemente no es lo mismo comprar 100 acciones a 300 que
tiene acciones al dólar no tenemos de acuerdo entonces pues de esta manera le
permito que cambie que se vaya ajustando a cada a cada dinámica esto en mi
opinión es mejor hacerlo así y luego trabajar en excel se provoca un problema
pero es más es más razonable que trabajar con todo el rato el mismo lotaje
para para esta diferencia de precios tan tan abrumadora porque el tanto el
nivel de efectividad como de riesgo varía de una manera espectacular ya
visteis algún ejemplo no tan extremo como como como este que es apple y lo
vimos también en el nasdaq si no recuerdo mal con unos datos que creo que
eran de apolo y ya visteis cómo cambia cómo cambiaba no el resultado año tras
año y por eso es es mejor entonces simplemente hacemos eso
este código ahora hace eso invierte todo el rato el 100% de la cuenta en cada
operación nada más para que se vaya ajustando eso lo hemos incorporado luego
os hablaré a alguien creo que preguntaba ahí el tema de haber extra range bien el
tema de haber extra range luego es un filtro los voy a explicar al final es un
filtro de volatilidad que ya ha implementado para luego explicaros
pero no quiero no quiero hablar de él aún no quiero hablar de él porque los
filtros y más en ese frame no siempre son fáciles de implementar y son a veces
no recomendable hacerlo pero bueno no he puesto para hablar de ello el final de
entonces tenemos clara la regla la regla de entrada bien cómo saldré porque yo
puedo entrar entro por un simple doncha de momento lo dejo así podría mejorar
tratar de trabajar la entrada pero vamos a dejarla en bruto es decir un doncha
puro antes os decía que hay varias maneras de interpretar o de procesar el
doncha aquí la que hemos implementado ahora es simplemente como decía que el
cierre sea este por encima del mayor cierre de 20 de balas o el mayor
máximo de 20 barras o el mayor lo que quiera de 20 barras o de n barras es de
20 ahora vale y cuando eso se produce voy a mercado en la apertura de la
siguiente vela eso ya se ha entendido claro bueno todavía no es cargado ahora
ya ha cargado pero no no procesa porque esto pasa muchas veces cuando para muchos
datos ahí está vale ahora lo hemos cargado en otro en un
bueno en el sectorial de tecnología en el sectorial de tecnología
las acciones en largo plazo son tan tendenciales que el lado largo es muy
fácil obtener ratos positivos pero bueno es fácil lo que decir que no
podamos aprovecharlo como ya os comenté vale entonces esto ahora mismo solo
entra por doncha y sale por un tp del 10% vale doncha como os decía antes y
tenéis ahí los pdfs se ha explicado en varios ellos él en sí no no
especificaba una salida como tal aunque es verdad que aquí en estas reglas habla
un poco de ello vale habla de esto habla de retorno pero no damos unas reglas
claras o que sí que fijaba para entrada pero él hablaba de un tendencial y
entonces el doncha en sí original muchos autores defienden que es así tiene que
salir cuando va por el contrario es una salida muy tendencial es decir dejarle
que hasta que que no vaya a hasta que no vaya corto mediante la otra lado pues
sigue largo vale sigue largo sería una posible una posible manera pero es
realmente muy tardía en cambio de esa lo que hemos hecho es implementar una
salida en la media central fijaros que al final un doncha aquellos y con los que
las bandas de bollinger las bandas de bollinger no es más que una desviación
sobre la media esta media que veis aquí pintada no sé si se ve muy bien la voy a
poner más gordita color que se vea un poco más bueno más que nunca más que
gordita pero la voy a poner blanca que a lo mejor así se va a ver más entonces
eso es la media de los mismos períodos de 20 de acuerdo de 20 ya está tenemos
los canales de 20 cierres y la media de 20 cierres de acuerdo la media de los
de los 20 de los 20 cierres mayores anteriores y esta es la media de los 20
cierres de todo el rato vale entonces yo puedo salir en esa media yo entro
por el canal de doncha pero ciego mediante ese medio yo eso ya lo
he implementado
esta es una manera ahora os enseño en el código de probar reglas decir que las
pongo en el código mediante un true false booleano el código le lo activo
desactivo no nuevamente esto es programación lo explico pero no queda
con la idea simplemente puedo activar o puedo desactivar la posibilidad de salir
por media si está en false no sale utilizando esa regla si está en true
sale utilizando esa esa media central vale si más no tiene mayor mayor
historia ahora le permito que salga por la media además también tiene metido el
stop además también tiene metido el tp el stop que se lo podría
perfectamente quitar vale ahora se lo voy a quitar y por lo tanto lo voy a
dejar podemos decir mucho más tendencial porque no le dejo le pongo cero si le
pongo cero lo inhabilito porque lo he probado así que si vale cero no
tú así lo dejo mucho más tendencial así va a dejar correr hasta que no se
salga de tal manera cuando haya tramos de tendencia fuertes pues no se va a
salir no se va a salir porque hasta que no pierde esa media pues no se sale
lógicamente los determinados momentos lo pierde y se sale no pero pero
mientras no lo pierde pues siempre está dentro en el lado largo también lo puedo
poner corto ahora os lo voy a activar y vais a ver cómo degrada mucho pero está
está puesto así sería otra posible salida rápida para un don chen luego por
supuesto todo esto lo evaluaremos ahora simplemente lo estamos planteando
vamos planteando posibilidades posibilidades que son de donde las
sacas pero estas las saco de la de la de la de la conferencia me dices hombre la
entrada en este caso hay muchas que las sacaré completas de manuales ella ya
hablo de este libro y veremos esto no es este libro bueno seguramente seguramente
casi todos los libros manuales completos van de don chan y este libro habla de
todos así ahora no recuerdo yo estoy seguro que habla de don chan
es que entonces bueno no está sacado específicamente de él pero también
está ahí están esos artículos que habéis visto esto con commodities está por
internet vale pero don chan como tal no es un setup claro de entrada que tenga
una salida pero sabemos que es una entraba tendencial la estamos probando en
gráfico diario y por lo tanto pues al final puedo salir o bien no salir o bien
no salir no salir por tp y poner solo stop o bien salir mediante alguna salida
también un poco lenta como la media también podría probar y lo probaremos
salir y habilito otra vez la salida esta no le meto el tp y le saco por esto de
un 5% y ahora sólo va a salir si cae un 5% no sale nunca que he hecho mal otra
vez en el código nos pensáis que es bastante natural que se ha comprado desde
aquí no ha caído un 5% no puede ser no puede ser que desde aquí no que hay un
5% por eso está mal programado pero tienes está mal programado pero para
esto esto acordaros con hablar de la evaluación preliminar esto aunque es
para explicaros no es la evaluación preliminar es probar es probarlo y verlo
todo en el código y comprobarlo de acuerdo que hace lo que debe existí
mucho en esto y que además me choca porque con los cabros programados que
no me dan gráficos y yo entiendo porque la única manera de verificar las cosas
es mirando gráficos entonces esto aquí hay algún error en el código 100% que
hace que desde aquí no se sale ya más porque vale porque no debe estar en
porcentaje a ver no debe estar en porcentaje no debe estar en el porcentaje
a ver déjame antes ver que he puesto lo que creo que he puesto he puesto a salgo
media fols algo de cortos fols filtrado no actúa ahora bar filtro luego los lo
cuento y precios top y precios 0.05 por ejemplo por probar no se sale más de
aquí no se sale no se queda se queda y comprado a teteno no cierra no cierra no
cierra sabes ha comprado al final vale paramos ahí me he equivocado es evidente
que me he equivocado vamos a ver si vemos que tenemos mal aquí donde está el
trailing lo veremos luego aquí se testa o ser distinto de la de cero vale y
preso mayor que cero por eso te plazas y te plazas por plazas esto por tipo en
value está bien alberto si va en futuro si distinto de cero y está por 7 a
espérate porque por el otro por posición no no es por acción esto es dinero por
acción pero este último a ver déjame verlo esto realmente sorprendente es que
es este se queda abierto el del 2002 a 13 20 si todo el resto pierden un 2 es
que realmente extraño porque mira esto pierden un dos está bien este que has
visto en 2002 13 20 si debe ser que no lo pone o algo lo debe poner una vez y lo
lo pone más a claro claro claro que haya que no estén en caña calla ya está ahí
está madre mía esto ahora tendría que decir aquello que digo a veces que es
para ver si estabais atentos claro claro es que es que no salta nunca de
esto porque no es trailing es que yo lo decía bien y no nunca nunca toca un
stop si no tiene salida por arriba no se sale nunca porque no es trailing no
tiene sentido es esto para si venga a ver todo el mundo lo ha entendido o sea el
esto el esto fijo es 12 93 claro nunca más toca 12 93 no sale nunca está
comprado toda la vida de acuerdo porque de ese sentido te he puesto así sin tp
no tiene sentido sin tp no tiene sentido sin tp tendría sentido como trailing que
también lo tengo en el código he preparado entonces así no puede salir
no salía nunca así o bien habría que meter también la salida por media es
gemitada además dos por ciento es muy poco sino no tenía ningún tipo de
sentido vale el que sí que tiene sentido es trailing que también lo
he implementado y muchos autores operan don chan contra el vale este es ahora os
lo voy a ahora lo vamos a lo vamos a poner bien como hemos definido el
trailing y que es un trailing aquel que no lo sepa bueno un trailing es un stop
que va actualizando que va actualizando a favor de tu posición pero no encuentra
en este caso en el lado largo quiere decir que a medida que el precio sube va
subiendo el stop esto que no hacíamos ahora esto que no hacíamos ahora aquí
sí que lo actualizamos también se podría hacer con el cierre pero lo
actualizado con el valor máximo que puede alcanzar un largo con qué campo
alcanza el beneficio máximo con él con el hike no con el máximo precio entonces
simplemente se va actualizando desde el máximo se le va restando un porcentaje
vale esto mismo que habéis visto ahora pero hecho contra el vamos a deshabilitar
el esto normal vamos a deshabilitar también la salida por media y ahora sí
le vamos a obligar a que salga por el stop trailing con un 0.05 por ciento pero
desde los máximos es decir en cualquier momento que retroceda un 5 desde el
máximo se sale vale se sale y vuelve otra vez a los canales normales de
esto vamos a ver si más o menos está bien también puede estar mal porque
parece poco esto de 5 esto no está bien a vale claro pero aquí ya bueno porque
claro como el cierre es muy abajo por ser muy abajo aquí por ejemplo desde que
entra ciega y hace máximo en 144 a ver si está es correcto es correcto es
es correcto no se ha inicializado no se ha inicializado por cero 95 debería
salir a 37 36 efectivamente no está no está bien inicializado vamos correctísimo
correctísimo no porque lo calcula cuando está largo entonces ahí al no
inicializar iniciar el cálculo ahí no le da tiempo no le da tiempo lo suelta al
cierre de ésta ya lo suelta
si marca posición igual a 1 en esta vela por ejemplo no calcula pero en esta se
calcula y hace max list trae bien a lo mejor viene con otro anterior y no
actualiza vale es largo de momento pero sí sí hay que inicializarlo aquí
lo inicializó al iniciar el al iniciar el bucle
el bucle bueno fuera del bucle que de consulta de posición puedo hacerlo si
da igual mientras esté fuera de ahí me va a valer esto es que no lo he
inicializado ahora es 5% que es bastante claro ahora me he pasado no no está bien
sabiendo tiene que estar bien ahora está por ejemplo 001 a ver este 206 con 15 206
con 15 por 99 204 208 202 abre y abre y abre y no me vale porque abre y a ver
este no abre vale se me vale será que máximo 202 con 28 por 0 99 200 con 25
sí sí saben saben en principio a lo fuera de clase lo miramos lo miramos
mejor no es raro no es raro y porque vamos a ir trabajando así haciendo las
cosas pero pero si se me ha olvidado una tontería en el código que es que hacer
entonces al final la variable no estaba actualizando no estaba actualizando si le
dejas un 5% claro es que esto es todo el sector tecnológico sí que vuelve muchas
veces 0 5 pero no vuelve tantas veces al final 5% es un esto pues prácticamente
volgado desde máximos y hay veces que aguanta mucho la posición a veces está
demasiado no esto no puede ser otra vez otra vez pero porque el algoritmo calcula
voy a desactivar el tréil y porque como puede ser aquí por ejemplo aquí saltaría
62 por 0 95 es 18 63 saltar aquí saltar aquí 0 a mar que posiciona igual a 1
aquí va calculando esto max list 0 menos hay menos presentable bueno sabes que
debe ser alberto que no salta como va actualizando pero no depende de la
volatilidad claro claro está mal está mal está mal está mal no no está mal no
está mal no lo entiendo porque está mal fuera del bucle pero no hay nada ahí no
hay no hay no hay no hay posición porque me lo actualiza siempre claro
de verdad de verdad en fin ya si me lo salvo inicializando otra vez
sí sí sí sí sí ya meto el corto ya hecho porque así ya lo dejo hecho no
se me olvide luego distinto de menos 1 en igual a trailing
short 0 bueno no es que no es un elemento no es correcto dale f3
si creo que debe estar bien venga pues nada para esto sirve la podría haber
dicho que lo he hecho precisamente pero lo he hecho precisamente pero es
necesario para más la cosa la veces falla porque no va porque no tal lo vas
depurando nos depuramos con print pero esto es una cosa tan sencilla que ya ya
sin hacer y nada sin hacer príncipe de bug ni nada pues ya lo hemos encontrado
pero hay veces que no hay manera es una tontería y no hay manera y al final
tienes que sacar las variables imprimirlas y ver por qué no estás
consiguiendo hacer en el código lo que quieres hacer la pantalla que al final
es lo que os digo al final esto era un problema de traducción de traducción de
la idea a código por eso al final hay que revisar bien primero como os dije
que hace lo que debe que no lees a futuro que aquí no se puede pero por
ejemplo si usarles python podrías perfectamente leer a futuro y todavía
tenías que verificar más más cosas aquí no podemos leer a futuro porque no
nos deja a un dato futuro vale bien ahora ya tenemos salida al 5% vamos a ver a
ver si efectivamente vamos a verificarlo 55 63 por 0 95 a 52 85
52 84 si de abajo en tres sesiones o siempre lo hace así vale pues ya está
ahora sí que está saliendo al 5 y ahora sí que ya se ve que es más normal vamos
a poner un 10 que será un trailing un poquito más holgado un poquito más
holgado y de hecho en larga en tendencia larga hay muchos autores que hacen esto
os lo digo que salen a 20% me consideran que es una tendencia bajista y se salen
a 20% de caída que es bastante pero como todo tiene su parte buena y su parte
mala quiere decir que va a salir volver mucho al mercado pero te va a mantener
tener dentro en las grandes tendencias la única manera de mantener las grandes
tendencias es esa pues es demasiado te va a dar un verdad muy muy elevado pero
como como vais a ver el retorno da muchísimo retorno es el que retorno da
muchísimo retorno da un provechado de 231 sólo 17 operaciones pero al final
pues se consigue subir problemas cuando hay toda esa costa de dada pues como
vais a ver bastante elevados bastante elevados de 60 porcientos y demás
este es el ejemplo no tiene por qué ser en este caso tan extremo para nada para
nada es recomendable así pero es el caso extremo de lo que os decía de
tendencia así sí que voy a tendencia puro y veréis ahí que tengo un ratio de
aciertos del 41% es ahora como es tendencial puro porque porque deja
correr mucho los beneficios acierta 41 por ciento de las operaciones pero tiene
un ratio de haber a ver los de 3.30 espectacular muy elevado más de cada
tres veces lo que pierde pero claro se deja mucho en el camino y provoca grandes
riesgos esta podría dejarse como un setup de salida en tendencia y luego
buscar uno más rápido simplemente usar este bastante más acelerado como ya
teníamos puesto por ejemplo la mitad en 10% donde va a seguir siendo tendencial
pero menos va a seguir siendo tendencial pero a ver qué va a estar ahí
seguramente 45 por ahí quizás 49 incluso se acerca bastante al 50 ya está
casi equilibrado ahí en acierto con fallos pero con una a ver de casi 3 en
2.80 como veis un profit factor muy elevado ha bajado el dragón
prácticamente la mitad pero al final está controlando un poco mejor el riesgo
esta es salida entraba don chan salida trailing nada más nada más este sistema
así este setup es un setup que probablemente vamos a tener que
evaluarlo probablemente sería válido probablemente sería válido sólo así
no digo con esta configuración de inputs de don chan y trelli pero aquí
fijaros que ahora mismo tenemos dos inputs tenemos más cosas pero ahora
mismo yo tengo dos inputs si quisiera ahora hacer un mapa a optimizar
está la haremos pero no quería hacer optimizaciones por no dejar el próximo día
haremos eso hoy quería plantearlas todas lo haremos y el próximo día ya
trabajarlas antes porque si no ya he dedicado un poco de tiempo a los errores
vale hasta ahí vale puede ser porque son cinco minutos pero optimizar vamos a
dedicar mucho tiempo perdido ahí que no vale la pena entonces yo las haré
previamente y las os las mostraremos la plantearé cómo hacerla y tal y luego os
mostraré resultados para ir avanzando pero siempre lo haremos como hoy
previamente explicando los conceptos y demás los podéis ver y luego a partir
de ahí yo os diré lo que voy a trabajar este lo haremos este lo haremos y con
entrada por don chan y salida por trelli y nada más nada más esto lo miraremos en
varios activos por todo esto que hemos dicho pero este ya podría ser un setup
completo podría ser un setup completo que quiere decir que es un setup
completo ahora yo lo evaluaría preliminarmente verificaría que hace
lo que debe tanto la entrada como la salida en distintos activos vería que
tiene cara y ojos en distintos activos distintos y luego lo llevaría a
analizar mediante una optimización que sí que le dejaría oscilar un poco porque
me interesa ver como os he dicho antes como varía y poder ver un mapa y poder
ver un perfil de optimización que luego puedo usarla o no usarla ya lo veremos
para elegir pero aún así de esa manera yo obtengo datos para recordar que
insistí mucho esto la teoría la optimización no sólo es para elegir
parámetros es un gran error de general de mucha gente o es que optimizan mucho
sigo que hizo mucho pero no quiere decir que optimice para necesariamente elegir
otro input en vez de 20 poner 18 en vez de veremos puedo hacerlo eso puede pero
puede que no puede que no porque a mí la optimización me permite mirar cosas
analizar datos entonces este sería un posible setup aquí ahora mismo lo tengo
cargado en un spdr que no deja de ser un índice por ejemplo podemos ver otro
podemos ver otro en este mismo setup que recuerdo que es don chan que veis en el
con cierres vale y salida por trailing al 10% desde el máximo que alcance
durante el trade y expuesto al 100% más o menos también le he metido una
penalización ya de comisiones 5 dólares por trade que eso es lo que cobra
comisión y le he metido un tick de slipage le he metido un tick y 5
dólares por operar por trade esto es lo que le he metido y está hecho con 100
mil dólares a 100% exposición calculado por como os he enseñado
dividiendo en la cuenta por el cierre hace cuánto tengo la cuenta 100 mil al
empezar vale pues 100 mil entre el precio por el cierre cuántas acciones
puedo comprar x y va siendo así y va teniendo en cuenta siempre el nuevo
capital para calcular las posiciones de esa manera voy usando el 100% de la
cuenta y vale este es el planteamiento que tenemos de momento ahora vamos a
ver otros planteamientos insisto pero este nos da 271 ya lo puedo poner por
ejemplo por ejemplo porque porque está en un ETF muy líquido
tremendamente líquido este ETF tiene un volumen
mientras os voy comentando las otras variantes que tengo en el código no
usadas ahora mismo ese podría ser un set up porque es un set up este porque yo
estoy en un diario sé que tengo seguramente pocos trade y por lo tanto no
quiero añadir demasiadas restricciones no quiero añadir demasiados filtros y no
quiero básicamente complicarme la vida entonces de entrada quiero probar un
set up muy básico y sencillo si con él puedo ganar dinero y controlar el riesgo
vale y eso partiendo de un tendencial como lo hago pues os lo he dicho si
quiero un tendencial y quiero dejar correr los beneficios quiero sacar un
tendencial necesito que corre la única manera que corre es no cerrar por tp
lógicamente todo el control del riesgo y por eso pongo un stop lo pongo tipo
trailing para ir subido al precio para ir acompañando podría usar otros y
si podía usar un parábolo xr que es otro indicador que para esto podía hacer
el trailing anclado con cierres podía hacer el trailing partido en vez de
calcularlo desde el máximo que devuelva sólo un porcentaje de las garancias que
gente que lo calcula así a mí me gusta mucho así como simplemente por el cierre
fácil intuitivo pocas pocos inputs sólo uno de hecho de acuerdo el porcentaje
que el resto del máximo y punto fácil fácil es básico que las ideas sean
fáciles y no las compliquéis en exceso no hace falta meter un trailing con tres
variables y no vale éste es una salida que podíamos haber extraído
perfectamente tengamos la experiencia que tengamos porque la entrada viene de
una revista y un trailing también lo podéis encontrar en mil revistas como
concepto viene implementado en la misma plataforma
si tú buscas un trailing esto ya está implementado y es una salida bastante
sencilla vale en cuanto a bueno me hago los cinco
minutitos de pausa que hace aprovecho para cargar esto vale y luego sigo
comentando los otros las otras posibles salidas y filtros que he creado para
explicaros y comentar posibilidades posibilidades que hay al respecto vale
así que hago una pequeña pausa que ahora sí que lo tengo preparado de cinco
minutitos y vuelvo mientras puedes escribir ahí y preguntar y vamos
comentando y contestando lo que para la grabación porque no hace falta meter
ahí cinco minutos extra
pues ya estamos ya estamos por aquí vamos a parar el reloj vosotros oíais la
musiquita del reloj no sé cuál es o no sé una como una musiquita tiene y no se
debe oír eso creo no se debe oír que ha comentado por aquí a alguien está
aprovechado para leer las preguntas pero a ver aquellos que nos están
iniciados con la programación eso es algo extremadamente normal de
programación la mayor parte del tiempo te buscas resolviendo problemas al final
una vez una vez ya se ha acabado es un momento que está hecho programar un
cuando está todo claro y tal cuesta muy poco rato pero muchas veces no hay
errores no consigues te das cuenta y la mayor parte se pasa resolviendo que
bueno que no podías haber repasado ya lo he repasado ya
lo que es que esto no está repasado está repasado varias veces está bastante
repasado pero ahora sí pues se te cola porque como hay varios setups de entrada
salida ahora activas uno activas el otro pues bueno no se me había colado se
me había colado pero no estaba repasadísimo no creéis que esto está
hecho directo sin repasar entonces comentaba antes el tema de la aprovecho
porque ya que he parado lo suelto aurelis me está siguiendo el tema de
la de la validación de led sí sí claro que básicamente te diría que de esto va
el curso entonces esto lo iremos viendo cada continuamente la próxima hoy de
momento lo que hemos visto de momento lo que hemos visto es validación en lo que
hemos llamado en la teoría de evaluación preliminar ahora vamos a la
siguiente fase pero hoy no lógicamente no dar tiempo en la siguiente haremos
esto que explicaba ahora que decía bueno ahora prepararé optimizaciones pero
esto todo esto va a ser va a ser la siguiente la siguiente clase hoy vamos a
definir todas las opciones que tenemos de análisis y para la siguiente clase yo
prepararé varias prepararé este setup que he dicho y otros y analizaremos
conjuntamente varios y veremos por qué si no etcétera evaluaremos el sistema
esto que con muy buen criterio de preguntas es lo que lo queremos haciendo
ese será el primero y lógicamente pues lo iremos haciendo con lo iremos haciendo
con muchos con muchos más no a ver que tenía alguna pregunta me ha sido abierto
eso perfecto ahora ahora lo explico cuando cuando llegue no comentaba
respecto a la pregunta que ahora va a salir va a salir el tema seguimos
seguimos con más opciones que hemos implementado en el código pero mientras
ya me ha cargado el sector financiero es tremendamente volátil y
saberlo como queda vale vamos a ver cómo queda con este mismo setup que
tiene runups chulos con este 10% le da margen le da un margen interesante pero
es aquí falsas entradas también que se las traga con patatas
vale pero seguramente es bastante bastante profit no es profit no es
porque mira que lo parece aquí seguramente es por la parte final
bueno claro también tiene un problema esto esto tiene un pro 20 no no está bien
está bien dimensionado pensaba que no tocará el tope de dimensión si tiene un
coste de comisiones muy elevado pero bueno se va adaptando se va adaptando
el tema es que cuando compras muchas acciones que ahora te meten mucha mucha
mucha slippage pero si si esta fase es tremendamente volátil que la caída se
los traga se los traga todos aquí mira si en el lema en la crisis de lema
brothers se los traga todos aquí vuelve a entrar vuelve a entrar con 20
vuelve a entrar por poco que está ahí justito y los cintura todos y no voy
aquí ya no se levanta muy bien perfecto interesante interesante interesante
bien seguimos viendo las otras las otras posibilidades el otro día recordar que
ya implementé la salida por tiempo es una salida que me gusta mucho pero el
existo si queremos un set up tendencial al final tenemos que dejar que ver no
hay muchas no hay muchas opciones ante esto muchas opciones podemos jugar con
estas dos combinaciones pensar que lo bueno lo bueno de tener pocos o casi
ninguno parámetro es que entonces puede ser cierto margen de optimizar y elegir
si yo por el tema de los grados de libertad que ya veremos cuando lo
trabajemos pero si no no no podría ver posibles filtros o posibles variantes de
entrada bueno espera que nos iba a explicar la salida la otra salida que
había que ya la vimos el otro día es salida por un número n de barras de
acuerdo está que estaba implementada el otro día para exit ya hemos visto
porcentaje de esto porcentaje de profit porcentaje de trailing es el que está
activada ahora salida por la media central de acuerdo salida por la media
central del mismo periodo que el canal la media central también podría haberla
hecha que no lo ha hecho sería bastante sería bastante de largo recorrido salir
en el canal contrario es decir esa de hecho la podemos sí que la tenemos
implementada porque en tres se son como tiene una particularidad que es muy
fácil de implementar pero mirar vamos a activar los cortos
vamos a activar los cortos que tenemos tenemos una variable booleana para operó
cortos y le pongo true y al operar los cortos hacemos una cosa ahora os lo
enseño a que no sepáis ahora va corto pero yo puedo evitar que vaya corto y que
eso lo usé para hacer largos vale la señal del corto la usé para hacer
largos ves así el corto aún va peor que el largo lógicamente pero lo que
voy a hacer es que la regla del corto y el sell short lo usé para exitarle y
ahora la regla del corto la usa para hacer además la de que tenga del esto
que tenga del esto de tal manera que en el momento en que se sale por la banda
de abajo se sale además del trailing tiene el trailing podría quitarle el
trailing mirar ese sería el caso extremo total de decir bueno entra largo por la
banda de arriba y sale por la banda de abajo no pero no lo he desactivado me
he equivocado no lo he activado porque no lo he activado en el cambio este que
he hecho he quitado la opción de desactivarlo a ver generado otro error
antes al hacer al solucionar el error de la actualización es generado otro porque
ahora no está adentro a marquete del mar que cero del marco positiva tal vez
esto está bien pues distinto de largo vale cuando está cero también lo
actualiza pero si no es mayor que cero no no no debe entrar aquí ya está y no
debe lanzar este ser no entiendo qué pasó ah no porque me falta el bikini
aquí ya está ya está ya está era un error bastante menor este este es este
en este es este en este es este en y me falta otro en aquí ahora no 3 ahora sí
había otro otro error al generar la actualización de variables he hecho otro error de
ahora sí que sale sólo por el canal es decir entra por el canal de arriba y sale
por el canal de abajo sería la opción probablemente más tendencial de todas
opción probablemente más tendencial de todas porque ahora cuando coge tendencia pues le cuesta
cerrar por debajo del canal y seguir como con el trillig no tiene 41 aciertos y aquí
no da profit probablemente por un mix de comisiones bastante elevado es la primera
parte según de muchos al 2009 o en el caso de lema ya hemos visto ahí que tiene muchas
entradas en la caída que no consigue evitar el daño esta es la clave de cualquier sistema
evitar el daño en su mal mercado esta es la clave la regla más importante de cualquier
sistema no va a ganar dinero cuando tiene un mercado hostil pero tiene que sobrevivir
me acuerdo que se no lo hace bueno no lo hace entonces luego tiene su buen momento pero no
compensa su mal momento en esta versión vale volvemos a lo que se explicaba la otra salidas
era la salida por tiempo ya las hemos visto todas tenemos ahora hemos visto la salida por
banda contraria ya hemos visto por media esto profit y trillig y vale exit yo puedo en lo que
ya no sería una versión también tendencial ya sería una versión para no buscar tendencia
exactamente y esto a veces dentro de puede tener un sentido lo que os decía en términos de cartera
es también muy muy importante recordar que al final el objetivo es este llegaremos un segundo
llegaremos a ello pero poco a poco al final depende de lo que yo tenga en la cartera puede
interesarme más una cosa en la otra entonces a lo mejor me puede interesar yo a lo mejor ya tengo
bastante tendencia y estoy buscando un tendencial pero mixto que no se quede más cercano al 50%
de aciertos y no quiero correr el riesgo de dejar correr tanta tendencia o tengo demasiado riesgo
ya porque tengo muchos tendenciales y no quiero quiero algo más estable pero puede ser entonces
puedo trabajar el sistema tratando de ser un semi tendencia si que entre en roturas de tendencia
pero voy a hacer que salga vamos a desactivar los cortos lo voy a dejar así para que salga por la
banda contraria no pero claro es imposible que salga por la media no va a salir va a salir por
el tru le pongo que como mucho este 10 días por ejemplo 10 días por ejemplo que salga por la media
y entonces pues bien sale o bien por la media o bien 10 días pero en este caso esto no tendría
mucho sentido de acuerdo tenía sentido más bien en este caso o bien el tru en el esto pero no
tendría mucho sentido dejarle salir por por la media y por la banda con lo cual anularía la salida
por cortos anularía la salida por cortos que eso me activa la media la salida la banda contraria
y aquí le podía meter un esto por lo mejor del 5% para vueltas un poco rápidas pues algo por tiempo
o por perdida de 5% por la por la media no es algo por el contrario de acuerdo veis es un setup muy
distinto realmente realmente es un sistema que está poco tiempo en el mercado que busca entradas
rápidas incluso aquí os diría más o sería más aquí sí que tendría más sentido porque ya estoy
fijando un tiempo para salir entonces y como pues vamos a poner pero si también no vamos a poner
porque si me vas a salir en 10 ver en 10 velas oye si ganas pero en este caso lo voy a poner el
doble ratio 2 a 1 2 a 1 profit 10 para el próximo día os explicaré otra cosa sobre esto que
solemos hacer que es relacionar uno con otro no meter más cosas ahora o sea esto mismo en
vez de poner un esto poner uno de ellos y los otros dos veces el esto por ejemplo una vez ir
1 1 2 ir por rato que solemos hacerlo así entonces ya aquí tengo 0 10 de profit 0 5 de esto
le voy a quitar la salida de la media vale y salida por tiempo es una salida bastante habitual es un
mix bastante habitual esto tp pero también tengo tiempo es decir si ninguno de los dos salta en
x barras me voy esto es bastante bastante habitual pues aquí con un esto bastante cercano y bueno y
esto pues daría como veis un sistema que está mucho menos tiempo en el mercado y que busca al
final con éxito con éxito no pero busca pues eso explosiones de entrar y sales si hemos conseguido
que hemos conseguido que de la cara poco ha mejorado un poco ha mejorado un poco sigue siendo esta
época muy mala pero que ya se ha aguantado mejor con esto no es saliendo pero sigue siendo
muy flojo en el tf financiero de acuerdo estas todas las salidas que hemos que hemos visto vale
bien en este mismo seta vale por no marearos os explico posibles posibles filtros de entrada
aquí hay uno hay uno que está instrumentalizado en el sentido que no ocurra que no ocurra esto
que veis aquí es decir que reentré y salga muy rápido es decir que una vez que sale necesita
esperar un determinado número de velas vale esto tiene bastante sentido porque si no caes un poco
en entrar y salir todo el rato y esto es eso de bar filtro que ponemos ahora silenciado sonido
reactivado alguien me había silenciado no sé quién ha sido pero alguien me había silenciado
alguno de vosotros vale por error si modismo de los cascos no pasa nada no pasa nada pilar pilar
estaba cansado de oírme y ha decidido silenciarme está no pasa nada pues nada lo dejamos y nada
perdón en la sabe pilar no me quiere seguir pues lo dejamos bueno pues lo que lo que lo que
digo la entrada ahora vez pasa más pasa como mínimo tres barras para entrar este simplemente
estos este tipo de filtros son habituales son habituales para evitar aquellos que programéis
o que ya habéis hecho algo de sentido que ya sabéis ahí de los dos tipos de alumnos
os habéis encontrado seguramente algún sistema que entra y sale y la misma vela entra
eso es una buena práctica no tiene mucho sentido salir para volver a entrar de acuerdo tiene mucho
sentido es decir entonces una manera de evitar eso es esto no poner un filtro a decir cuántas
barras estas fuera es buena práctica para para analizar el sistema ya con eso y trabajarlo así
porque si no no tiene mi opinión mucho mucho sentido esto lo hace con esto cuántas barras
tiene que pasar desde que ha salido la anterior tres una palabra reservada que tiene tres o que
no hayan operaciones porque si no con esto no entraría vale esto es para evitar que no
entre total tres igual a cero total tres es una variada para reservar tres eso que cuenta el
número de tres totales y que sólo se actualiza cuando cierras posición con eso puedes usarlo
para este tipo este es muy menor el otro filtro un poco más elaborado y que creo que es importante
que ya lo vamos a plantear hoy como como algo interesante que vamos a darle bastantes bastantes
vueltas es ya hable la teoría mucho de la volatilidad y os dije que la volatilidad es
uno de los mejores vectores para operar tanto como filtro como para medir la gestión monetaria como
incluso vector principal de operativa aquí está no ha implementado pero otra otra variable que
se podría haber incrementado incorporado es decir que en el momento de entrar la vela fuera
más volátil o menos que lo anterior esto puede puede hacerse hemos implementado un filtro de
volatilidad bueno que de hecho es un poco eso es un poco eso que he dicho ahora lo que quería
decir es que es un filtro de precios es decir muchas veces antes he dicho mira me acabo de
acordar que he dicho que lo explicaría no ha explicado pero bueno va ligado con esto por eso
me he acordado que el clásico don chian se puede plantear de varias maneras aquí fijaros que os he
planteado la entrada que volvemos ahora a repasar distintas entradas por eso me sale que el cierre
tenga que ser por encima del máximo pero yo podría haber hecho que la regla fuera simplemente todo
el rato que cuando está cerrado evaluará esto comprar a x contratos en stop en el canal de acuerdo
igual el código es lo de menos vale que en vez de necesitar que cerrará por encima que
comprar en esto todo el rato en el canal entonces en vez de comprar ahí se entiende la idea no que
cambiaría vamos a ver un par o tres eso también sería en vez de comprar a dios a ver hacer
circulitos ahí en vez de comprar aquí yo hubiera comprado aquí igual que aquí en vez de comprar
aquí hubiera comprado o ahí en ese máximo o aquí se entiende un poco la idea no es decir
comprar en esto pero el máximo todo el rato de esta manera yo todo el rato voy poniendo la orden
todo el rato todo el rato la orden es la línea la línea azul hasta que entra luego ya no es otra
posibilidad es una posibilidad que opera más más rápida con más fallos a mí me gusta bastante así
como está como está puesta ahora pedirle un cierre por encima pero es depende es depende realmente
de hecho lo que os decía lo que os decía antes va todo un poco relacionado y lo que también lo dije
en las prácticas esto es verdad que se cultiva con la experiencia en el sentido común que muchas
veces ya digo se cultiva mucho con la con las experiencias en experiencia es complicado tener
sentido común en algo porque al final se va adquiriendo por propia experimentación en lo
que os decía antes de los cierres en relación al gráfico diario y demás en el gráfico diario
así que yo creo que creo no creo que nos gusta más esta manera que hemos planteado aquí es decir
que cierre por encima de la banda pero en entraría entraría seguramente iríamos más a directamente el
contando que te vas a quedar dentro o sea que vas a salir al final del día de acuerdo como máximo
en el que buscas una explosión que buscas una explosión ahí sí ahí sí que entonces todavía
es más será más importante filtrar pero es verdad que cuando vas a la intradía sobre todo
si vas a timeframes cortos filtrar ya no es tan problema y tal puede ser un problema aquí puede
serlo porque si yo tengo solo 200 operaciones a filtrar empieza a ser complicado por el número
de por el número de tres que voy a obtener porque al final filtrar quita tres y es muy fácil caer
una sobreutilización es tan fácil que casi es mejor es más recomendable no hacerlo no no no
filtrar pero si yo me voy a entraría esto la tortilla se gira mejor tengo mil tres o tengo
quinientos tres o tengo dos mil tres tengo mil bueno si filtro me quedo con 600 700 si no tengo
tampoco muchos inputs probablemente puedo conseguir a un sistema robusto con esas cifras entonces
cuando yo me voy a entraría a filtrar ya no es tan problema entonces ahí sí que a lo mejor iría
más al stop directo pegado a la banda pero a ver qué filtro usaba para entrarle más en unas notas
pero al cierre en gráfico diario quizás mejor así como se ha planteado es decir pedirle que haga
un cierre por encima de la barra al final estoy confirmando que el precio rompe una secuencia
de máximos podría pedirle más cosas podría pedirle dos cierres si quisiera por código podría
programar que fueran dos cierres o podría programarle ese es un filtro bastante bastante
interesante y que hemos de hecho usado hacerlo todavía más conservador pero aquí ya digo no
tenemos muchos tres pero si tú lo necesitaras podrías pedirle que toda la vela estuviera por
fuera es tremendamente exigente y con un canal de venta seguramente tendría que ser un canal más
corto nos va a costar mucho conseguirlo nos va a costar mucho conseguirlo que toda la vela cierre
por encima del canal vale esto es más típico con con medias o con bandas de bollinger de acuerdo
pero con un canal de don chan es complicado conseguirlo puede ser
o que al menos que el cierre y el cierre lo es el mínimo también buscar varios varios campos o
alguna cosa de este tipo alguna cosa de este tipo pero ya digo con bandas muy lentas es muy
difícil con bandas muy lentas es muy bueno entonces volviendo ya explicado la otra opción
de la del don chan de acuerdo que siempre decido ir contra la banda de acuerdo contra la banda en
esto vamos a ver ahora él espera que lo voy a dejar esto que he hecho comentado para que no
de error está en la otra era un filtro de volatilidad de acuerdo que para eso está puesto
este aterrizante se ha visto que preguntaba alguien alguien por ahí los sistemas de breakout vale los
sistemas de breakout o sea vamos a ver en la volatilidad donde tengo yo mis notas sobre esto
a ver a los reyes como creo tienes no sí sí es el show eso es el show no yo es el show
de la veras pero realmente no quería ponerse equivocado equivocados a que gehen el a ver a
el a ver a su reyes pero en si antes preguntaba alguien y no pero que me equivoco el a ver a
ser el reyes la única diferencia entre el reyes y el true range es que el reyes es el rango de
toda la vela sin contar el gap anterior, es decir, high menos low, eso es el range, high menos low,
y el true range es el high menos low, pero si hay gap cuenta el close anterior, ¿se entiende?
se entiende un poco la idea, es decir, el, porque antes lo preguntaba alguien por aquí, o sea,
el range, a ver un momentito que me he liado aquí yo solo, vale, o sea, el range es esto, ¿ves? high
menos low, el true range en cambio, el true range, bueno, es el true high menos el true low,
es más fácil en el que tengo yo, es más fácil en el, espérate, que te voy a enseñar el nuestro
cómo lo calculamos, el de porcentaje, que además le dije que lo enseñaría, y esto es exclusiva,
el normalizado, ¿qué hace eso? normalizado, que esto es nuestro, esto es, lo único que lo
dividimos por typical price, como yo os había dicho antes, pero es el mayor de tres, el high menos
low, que eso sería el range, pero también el cierre anterior menos el low, o el máximo anterior
menos el cierre anterior, este es el valor del true range, esto ahí en código supone lo que os he
dicho, que es la diferencia entre el máximo y el mínimo, pero tiene en cuenta el cierre anterior,
para restarlo a bien el high o bien el low, o bien el low, entonces cuando haya un gap lo considera,
es decir, donde se ve muy claro, por ejemplo aquí, mirad, el true range de esta vela es la
diferencia entre el máximo y el cierre, en cambio la del range sigue siendo solo el máximo y el
mínimo de esta vela, entiende, ¿verdad? el máximo menos el cierre es el true range, el máximo menos el
low es el range, esa es la única diferencia entre el range y el true range, entonces se puede hacer
el average true range y el average range, porque es el average de los distintos range o el average de
los distintos true range, no tiene más historia, pero aquí abajo deben estar los dos true ranges,
bueno, pero como he hecho el código, por lo mejor estoy diciendo una cosa y no es correcta,
no es correcta, a ver que he abierto aquí ahora 14 cosas, fuera, fuera, fuera, fuera, fuera, fuera,
aquí está, no, no, es true range con true range, si, si, es true range con true range, me he equivocado aquí,
aquí tengo que poner un true range, a ver que lo voy a quitar, average range, aquí añado un average true range 20,
porque ahora lo he equivocado, lo tengo que meter en la escala del otro, que es el gráfico 2,
lo pongo en el histograma, ese va en uno encima del otro, pero sé por qué queda ahí tan solo,
no sé por qué solo se ve ahí, a ver, ha salido los dos, bueno, pues nada, ahora sí, ahí está,
vale, esto no es más que uno encima del otro, porque eso al final lo que relaciono es la
volatilidad de la vela actual con relación a la volatilidad anteriores, de acuerdo, esto es un
filtro que al final busca una cosa que a veces es contraintuitiva, porque tengo que unas notas,
no quisiera decirlo mal, pero bueno, de algún momento a otro las encontraré, de algún momento a otro las
encontraré, pero no lo encuentro, a ver, aquí, cuando tenemos, sabéis que la volatilidad, la volatilidad es
totalmente círclica, aquí se ve realmente con bastante claridad, voy a ocultar ahora el de uno,
voy a ocultar un momento el de uno para explicaros esto, para explicaros esto, luego lo vuelvo a
poner, la volatilidad es cíclica, de manera más, hay activos que más, activos que menos, al final
esto es un índice, pero es financiero, que está bastante sometido a una época concreta, y de hecho
aquí no lo vemos del todo bien, lo vais a ver mejor en el que tenemos nosotros el normalizado,
en este se ve muy bien, lo voy a poner para verlo, luego lo quitaremos, luego lo quitaremos, este
ahora lo voy a ocultar también para verlo mejor, que me interesa explicaros esto, que es de concepto,
aquí se ve un poco mejor, aunque está bastante, este gráfico está bastante roto, no roto porque
esté roto, sino porque al final tuvo unas volatilidades tan brutales, y casi no hay nada
comparable a ello, pero bueno, la volatilidad como veis es bastante cíclica, hay momentos que entra
como veis en momentos de mucha volatilidad, luego de poca, entonces es bastante cíclica,
creo que se ve bastante claro, tiene sus picos del 8 a 9, que son bastante bestias, y esta rayita
que veis es el 203%, no sé si se ve bien, es un media histórica, pero es la media histórica de este
concreto que es el sector financiero, entonces al final los sistemas breakout, que es lo que
estamos buscando ahora, y esto aplica más a los breakouts que a los tendenciales, es decir,
aquí como es un breakout lo he aprovechado para explicaroslo, pero sinceramente aquí no creo,
no creo que lo podamos aplicar por lo que os decía, primero porque conceptualmente es un poco más
dubtoso, más dudoso, tiene un pequeño matiz, ahora os lo explico, pero sobre todo por lo que
os decía antes el número de trades, que vamos a tener que juntar activos, va a ser más complicado,
no digo rotundamente no, pero digo que es más difícil y más arriesgado, cuando vamos a sistemas
diarios, y ya no te digo semanal o mensual, entonces conceptualmente ¿por qué? porque al final el
sistema breakout, donde es ideal, es lo que os decía en los temas intradiarios, por ejemplo,
este mismo sistema, que ya lo veremos más adelante, cojeremos este mismo y haremos estas
pequeñas modificaciones que hemos hecho para intradiar, lo probaremos en intradiar, por ejemplo,
lo podemos probar por ejemplo en el oro, un activo tendencial, en el petróleo, lo probaremos los dos,
trataremos de sacar, a ver si lo sacamos, un dungeon que nos funcione en el oro y en el petróleo,
pero lo buscaremos como breakout solo, no como tendencial, aquí ahora hemos partido tendencial,
estamos viendo todas las posibilidades, pero como os he dicho para el día siguiente lo trabajaremos
sobre todo como tendencial y trataremos de evaluarlo como tendencial. Si fuera breakout,
volatilidad y breakout, entonces la diferencia principal entre un tendencial por volatilidad y
breakout es simplemente que el volatilidad y breakout le busco cerrar pronto, es decir,
busco una explosión de volatilidad, la cojo y me voy para casa, recuerdo, eso es un poco
planteamiento, en cambio el tendencial busca largas tendencias, por lo cual necesita activos
con buena tendencia, que las acciones no es el mejor, de hecho este sectorial va mal porque
como veis aquí simplemente no hay tendencia, es decir, el gráfico está en el mismo sitio,
estos son años y está en el mismo sitio, vamos para allá y siempre en algunos momentos se cae,
pero fijaros ahí la de tiempo que está lateral y si al final gana algo de altura,
pero realmente no tiene nada que ver, como habéis visto en la tecnología, dejaros el precio
arriba, está en 38 y al principio del gráfico está en 19, ni tan solo ha doblado en años,
es el 2000, cuando habéis visto el nasdaq apple que estaba por debajo de uno y estaba en 300,
que no nos da diferencia, pero es claro, le cuesta porque buscamos tendencia en algo que
no tiene tendencia, entonces claro, pero es al olmo, eso es lo primero, trabajar en mercado
que funciona, pero bueno, se ha querido probarlo porque ya sabía que era hostil, quería verlo,
a lo que iba, entonces en un volatilidad y breakout al uso yo busco una explosión de
volatilidad y cuando se da una explosión como la volatilidad cíclica, cuando es más probable que
haya una explosión o que haya una rotura que sea buena, es tras un periodo de contracción,
tras un periodo de contracción, por lo tanto a mí, contrariamente a lo que defienden muchos
manuales, que defienden que las roturas tienen que ser con volatilidad, bueno, es que sí que
tiene sentido el concepto de que tiene que ser con volatilidad, pero realmente tienen que ser
en un momento donde la volatilidad no sea alta, en un momento donde la volatilidad no sea alta,
porque si la volatilidad ya es alta es probable que el movimiento ya se haya dado, por esto os decía
que es más dudoso y más contradictorio con un tendencial, porque un tendencial por definición
entra tarde para salir aún más tarde, es decir, un tendencial entra cuando hay tendencia y ahí sí
que es más dudoso y puede ser que entres en un inicio de una tendencia que empiece una expansión
de volatilidad y acabe siendo buena tendencia, pero no en un volatility breakout que lo que yo busco
es una expansión de volatilidad, si la expansión de volatilidad ya se ha producido es señal de que
probablemente el mercado ya ha desarrollado un movimiento tendencial y por lo tanto nuestra
configuración probablemente será menos eficaz, así que es en las fases de contracción de la
volatilidad cuando el mercado aún no ha desarrollado el movimiento, ahí es donde sí que yo sé que no
ha desarrollado el movimiento y por lo tanto lo aunque pueda parecer contraintuitivo en un
volatility breakout que no es exactamente este, eso es diario lo que explicaba ahora, aprovecho
para introducirlo porque como os digo la principal diferencia entre un volatilidad y un tendencial
prácticamente es las salidas, la entrada puede ser igual, la entrada puede ser igual, por eso lo explico
aquí cambiaría bastante la salida, entonces aquí veis un poquito el ejemplo que os digo, aquí yo
tengo una clara tendencia y viene acompañada de una clara subida de volatilidad, entonces me
puede decir hombre pero sí pero aquí todavía queda mucha tendencia, bueno sí claro esto una
vez visto todos listos claro pero es verdad que ya se ha desarrollado el movimiento, en tendencia
tendría sentido pero si yo busco explosiones es más probable que hayan explosiones aquí que aquí
se entiende eso es un poco el concepto y por lo tanto os puedo asegurar que los volatility breakout
como funciona mejor es con filtro de volatilidad que detecte cuando es baja en relación a la
histórica y cómo podemos implementar esto pues realmente muchas maneras como casi todo el concepto
este es el concepto de acuerdo el concepto es yo en un volatility breakout me interesa más entrar aquí
a lo ideal es aquí, entonces a mí me interesa eso suele ir mejor en esa de esta manera además
tiene menos riesgo porque estamos entrando en volatilidades más bajas y tienen menos riesgo
entonces cómo podemos implementar esto en el código bueno pido que aquí aunque también aporta y
os lo digo que aporta si cerramos ahora lo vamos a hacer un poco por la tibre que vale pero vamos a
cambiar de activo porque este ya hemos visto que sobre todo el lado largo es bastante dudoso como
volatilidad y breakout vamos a bueno cualquier acción es bastante explosiva bueno hemos visto
lo de lo de facebook no pues mira vamos a ver a ver qué tal facebook por meter otra que vaya
cargando y mientras vamos al código vale yo tengo este filtro que lo tengo aquí con una
condición programado pero que no actúe ahora lo voy a dejar que actúe vale como que el true range
que al final ya habéis visto lo que era es el rango de una vela sea menor que el true range el
average true range del periodo del canal que son 20 por efecto si fuera otro pues se cambiaría
calculado la vela anterior esto lo que decía antes y le añado un filtro le añado un multiplicador a
este a este vector para poder trabajarlo que si lo dejo en uno quiere decir que simplemente la
volatilidad de esta vela sea menor que la volatilidad de las últimas 20 si modifico esto
pues puedo modificar la sensibilidad de cuánto cuánto hago esto grande pequeño este pero así
por defecto lo puedo dejar en uno creo que creo que creo que es como está y a partir de ahí pues
podemos analizarlo cuando acabe de cargar de cargar el gráfico vale y este sería un posible
filtro de volatilidad esto como lo añadido yo a la regla de entrada posiblemente a la entrada
es que antes había dicho que es que no estuviera no le daba muchas vueltas a esto porque me daba
igual pero lo repasamos ahora la condición para entrar largo en realidad era que condición 1
fuera true pero lo tenía activado en todo para que no molestara condición 1 es esto que he dicho es
decir que la volatilidad esté como yo creo que es más favorable para que haya una ruptura buena
si no prefiero entrar vale si la condición 1 no da true no entraría que es esta volatilidad 2 que
no esté largo que haga menos de tres barras o una que haya salido del mercado a que como mínimo
perdón haga tres barras y que al menos haya hecho una operación vale esa es la regla para entrar
cuando esto es afirmativo si el cierre es mayor que la banda entra si no se da esto que esto ya
digo el único cambio que implementamos ahora es este filtro de volatilidad de acuerdo este filtro
este filtro de volatilidad vamos a ver si ha cargado esto y si no ha cargado cargaremos
apel que ya tengo los datos y porque además cuando tanta para va cargando vamos a pasar a
diario porque da igual ahora para para ir más rápido vale y así lo podemos un momentito
a su momentito y cargar los que no los tiene pero a lo que tenga lo que tenga vale si ves
cargar un momento y ya está no nos da igual porque sólo para enseñaros esto vale yo de entrada
tengo como voy a breakout voy a breakout aquí sí que vamos más bien a tp vamos más bien a tp vamos
a vamos a suponer que saliera en 10 velas a velo dejamos vale y que vamos a tp bueno vamos a dejarlo
así 5 5 y 10 y con 10 3 se tiene que quedar fuera pero corto sual y tengo el filtro activo
ahora tengo el filtro activo no tengo no tengo activo no no tengo activo no porque aún he
compilado está como antes de cero está sin activar vamos a ver qué fito tiene mejor aquí
no funciona aquí por defecto tal como está ahora que es más un volatilidad breakout que está 49
está ahí justito porque porque le he puesto el doble si ahora lo igualo no se me ha ido el informe
ahora como lo pillo aquí ahora como me cago en 10 ahora como te pillo yo de aquí espérate un momento
aquí si yo ahora si yo le igualo le igualo tp y esto los dos los pongo al 10 como sale
por 10 y ahora solo quiero que salga y a veces que se va solamente abajo y que salga en 10 pero
si estoy en 53 ya lo he hecho más más breakout que ya no tiene ratios sentenciales ya está ahí más
más justito vale y al final pero es que muchas veces sale por 10 al final estoy buscando explosiones
que no que no pilla porque no hay tanta explosión en el diario que eso sería y alguna aquí ves pero
la mayoría al final no explota pues vamos en 10 velas de sales no quiero quedarme en el mercado
pero ahora le implemento le implemento este otro este otro filtro a ver qué efecto qué efecto provoca
estoy con 133 de profit factor ahora activo la condición no estaba activa y tengo fijaros
128 3 se va a bajar seguramente y trae tu referencia a espera que el max bar me ha petado el max bar
esa es una opción que no tengo están 20 no porque peta que miro más atrás de 25 vale esta la vuelvo
a desactivar la vuelvo a activar para ver cómo quedaba bueno un poquito mucho peor carlos mucho
peor así ya perdió 23 en este caso carlos que va mucho peor esa condición ahora que
ver que la tengan uno y realmente quitarle la salida por tiempo que solo va a 10% de esto
es por ciento de tp y ahí vas es por ciento de esto es por ciento de esto es prácticamente
elevado es 57% ya lo hemos convertido entrando en ruptura lo hemos convertido en una antitenencia
totalmente al final las salidas como yo os comenté es lo que marca mucho el carácter y ahora vuelvo
a activar el filtro que nos provoca sigue peorando un poco el ratio profit factor no sé en otros
como ha ido a ver por ejemplo el riesgo de más vamos a ver este 0 54 aquí en principio
no parece rentar así la opción por defecto esto sí que en estos casos habría que ver normalmente
va por debajo de uno por debajo de uno con esto mide también un poco el carácter vamos a hacerle
muy rápido muy breve y esto es instrumentar totalmente simplemente para ver cómo oscila
a ver esto que me da 021 bastante rápido esto diario no tardar nada bueno entonces hacemos más
antecedencial claro si fijaros así como en cero dónde están los trades aquí veis que en estos
no actúa 74 12 y donde en uno y medio filter a poco no no lo quiere en este caso facebook no
lo quiere no quiere este filtro de actividad de acuerdo en este caso no no no le aportaría
no le aportaría nada pero ya digo ya os digo esto normalmente es más útil en tendencia y no quiere
decir en todos los activos que vaya a funcionar al final la volatilidad es bastante característica
en cada cada índice y realmente ya incluso visualmente fijaros que es es es muy abrupto
facebook las acciones en sí siempre son mucho más volátiles que los índices y son bastante
complejas de operar para otras volatilidad al final recordar que siempre sobre todo nosotros al
principio a no ser que te podamos en una cartera gigantesca no es recomendable operar en acciones
siempre más recomendable operar índices al menos en estos tipos sbr que hemos dicho aquí
tienes el que equivale al nasdaq así le quito bueno voy a poner este porque porque ya lo tengo
cargado pero podíamos cargar a bueno tenemos que algar el cuco como como si el diario no tiene
problema a ver aquí qué tal qué tal se nos da aquí ahora estamos otra vez con volatilidad con
tres barras seguramente con ratios por encima del 50 por ciento en 61 porque estoy entrando
en ruptura pero estoy cortando los beneficios estoy cortando los beneficios y por eso al final
como muchos bueno muchos más no hago más trade pero realmente voy a no dejo correr los beneficios
vale aquí ahora vamos a ver el inicio porque me interesa verlo no debería de tener un efecto
en uno tan dramático pero ahora vuelvo a activar el filtro veis aquí sí que hay una mejora hace
uno veis ha salido a 211 181 mejora va a activar el filtro ha provocado una mejora ha reducido el
número de trades fijaros en los tres vale 81 caros aquí 81 lo vuelvo a desactivar y está con
uno no de variable ver como se ha quedado con el cero sita anterior igual no se ha quedado con
el 1 y medio antes que lo voy a lo voy a poner en uno para que así no tenga sesgo no voy a
poner en uno que no tenga sesgo a ver si es un efecto negativo positivo ahora están uno y
ves tiene dos 211 con 81 trade se lo quito tiene unos 65 con 80 trades es el cambio es notable
aquí sí que se nota bastante el sesgo de volatilidad es decir simplemente le he dicho
sólo entra cuando la volatilidad es un poquito más más baja vamos a ver si vemos alguna una
operación así por aquí cercana muy clara para que vuelva esto visualmente a ver si alguna de
estas bueno estas de por aquí seguramente no sé si aquí se barra alguna seguro o alguna profit y
ahora ahora sí que voy a hacer una cosa porque para ver el cuando estás mirando el sistema por eso
tengo así cuando estás mirando el sistema realmente es mejor tener los indicadores más suavizados
porque si no no ves nada no ves las rayas entonces por eso al final estoy acostumbrado siempre a
tenerlo como más clarito pero claro que para explicaros distinto cuando estamos aquí en la
parte como ahora que estamos más bien ya viendo el sistema que antes nos estaba explicando la idea
donde sí que era interesante ver ver los los indicadores el precio ahora ya el precio
no me importa tanto ahora ya veo mejor las las rayas no del sistema entonces ahora aquí tengo
ahora vuelvo a activar el filtro a ver si vemos algunos tres que elimina aunque no ha eliminado
cambiado los precios de entrada pero no ha eliminado es igual ya habéis visto que sí que provoca una
cierta una cierta mejora una cierta mejora de seguramente las entradas y eso que aquí va muy
largo va muy largo tp en esto realmente está bastante tendencial pero aún así pues ya veis
que aporta cierto cierto valor se que lo le ponemos le forzamos mucho que salga muy rápido
mucho mal aquí le forzamos que salga muy rápido pero otra vez simétricos es decir estoy forzando
a que se comporte bastante anti tendencialmente porque no le dejo correr rápidamente lo saco lo
saco lo saco vale pero ahora sí bueno como es un activo que ha subido mucho pues se da
profites interesantes he hecho vamos a activar los cortos ya para acabar vamos a activar los
cortos activar los cortos pero le vamos a dejar cortos normales cortos apuros a ver qué tal qué
tal es capaz de gestionarlo con esto simétrico luego le subiremos el profit lógicamente pierde
lógicamente pierde pierde pierde bastante con los cortos no consigue no consigue lógicamente
la tendencia al alza es fuerte y le hemos dado muy pocas opciones para salir más que tp y esto
que hemos dejado poco margen en cortos en cierta variable se pueden hacer nosotros hacemos que no
seguís lo sabéis pero realmente aquí la tp es muy cercanos y de hecho funciona más bien dejarle
un poco más de margen y la tp es como que ir al tp al tp rápido y la tp rápido porque si no no
da margen para para cortos hay que ir un poco un poco al revés pero ahora lo que me interesaba lo
quería ver era un poco activar ahora activar ahora el filtro aquí con el corto activado
ver qué efecto tenía ahora estamos en uno aquí sí que empeora con el corto activado no consigue
mejorar con el filtro volatilidad y es normal porque la volatilidad del largo del corto se
comporta de manera muy distinta seguramente requerirían un filtro un filtro distinto y para
un sistema diario es enviable es decir esto ahora lo estamos mirando en el diario pero como ya os he
comentado he querido introducirlo porque al final he desarrollado el concepto de tendencial y volatilidad
el mismo mismo día y hoy lo que me interesaba era esto desarrollar este concepto iremos
desarrollando los conceptos de distintos sistemas usando ejemplos porque eso es la parte práctica
un poco de la teoría y luego por supuesto hacer los sistemas completos bien hecho o sea este ahora
el próximo día lo desarrollaremos como tendencial como he dicho pero yo sé querido introducir la
la parte de tendencia volatilidad de cómo de cómo funciona y cómo ese punto en común que tienen
de prácticamente pueden usar la misma entrada pero las salidas lo cambia todo la salida lo
acuerdo había una pregunta por ahí pendiente del disco lo teníamos hay una que ha preguntado
ahí durante la clase del disco pero ya la no tiene mucho que ver con la clase de hoy ya lo
contestamos en otro momento del directo sólo tengo esta marcada veo alberto de aureli no que
decía que ejemplos ejemplos de mecanismos para la identificación de tendencia el lateral santo
bueno no santo grial no realmente esa es la gran la gran una de las grandes pero sí que hay si
que hay trabajaremos de hecho tengo pensado tengo pensado hacer una clase sólo de eso sólo de
eso vale lo que llevamos los regímenes de mercado en el argot más técnico que es un poco lo que
has hecho tú no sólo es tendencias al final tenemos seis tipos de mercados aureli seis tipos
de mercado que son la mezcla la mezcla entre tendencia y volatilidad en los tres estados
alcista lateral bajista volátil no volatil por el volatilidad es dos estados que podríamos ahí
dividir la volatilidad creciente creciente podrías podrías aún dividirlo más de esos seis pero en
general esos seis marcan bastante marcan bastante y con esos seis puedes tratar de controlarlo con
filtros de este tipo que te he comentado es un camino es un camino que hay varios hay también
cosas que tengo pensado ver pero eso sí que lo veremos bastante más adelante porque es complejo
y no quiero hasta que ya estéis más rodados de tema empezar a hablar de temas del bix de la
estructura del bix de las cosas muy avanzadas vale pero se usa para esto se usa para esto la
estructura del bix puede usarse como filtro volatilidad pero en realidad el concepto es
este que es lo que me importa ahora mismo los conceptos filtro de volatilidad es decir filtrar
operaciones que o bien son con volatilidad muy alta o bien son con volatilidad muy baja o bien
son con volatilidad creciente volatilidad de crecientes estas magnitudes dependiendo del
sistema me puede ser un muy buen filtro y liga mucho con el régimen de mercados con esto que
me preguntas pero me dices mecanismo para indicar tendencia lateral bueno tendencia lateral en la
teoría hablamos hicimos una práctica que también haremos también haremos trabajo de este tipo en
algún momento de las prácticas pero quería antes plant quería empezar porque sé que os gusta quería
más de la clase primera desarrollar un sistema entonces ya la pasada hablamos de las bases de
datos por petición popular y introduje este y ahora vamos a acabar ese sistema luego ya seguramente
volveremos a hacer cosas de búsqueda de ideas como puede ser puede ser eso que comentas también que
liga un poco con la búsqueda de ideas en el entorno tendencial en el entorno tendencial liga con
perfil activo y esto que me comentas tú vale pero ya digo la teoría hablamos hicimos una práctica
esta vez que estaba la de x estaba que os hablé del coeficiente de jugos que esto es el consenso
utiliza mucho eso yo os puedo decir que puedes defenderte bastante con con aterres ya de x para
medir un poco esto que te digo de volatilidad de tendencia volatilidad para medir un poco que
activos más tendencial y demás usé concretamente este el a este normalizado y usé el adx también
con el histórico también así con estas dos cosas que te pueden servir comparando activos para ver
activos más tendenciales porque como tienes la media histórica ese valor esa línea que ves en
medio es la su valor histórico el valor histórico entonces con eso puedes ir viendo un poquito los
activos que históricamente tienen un sesgo y cuidados no quiere decir que siempre lo sean
al final las medias sabes lo que tienen que centra mucho los datos pero puede puede servirte
para eso que tú puedes poner el histórico abajo en 20 te pones a ver el adx en 20 lo pones todo
en el mismo y a partir de ahí pues puedes ver puedes ver un poquito pues eso lo que tiene una
media 19 alrededor de 20 es bastante habitual pero puedes ver cuál es más y menos por aquí
ponés un activo antes hemos visto el financiero pues yo te pongo eso vas a ver que es menor que
esto seguro ahora es cuando me deja mal no y aquí tiene más pero para que me va a sorprender de
manera y eso que a la baja ha tenido algunos momentos porque si no de 24 pues no te creas
no te creas me dejaba bastante regular me deja bastante porque lo esperaba más bajos
pero es verdad que tiene mucho menos histórico que tiene mucho menos histórico tiene muchísimo
menos histórico yo sé que tiene momentos bastante buenos de tendencia pero tiene momentos
bastante llanos puede servir puede servir para para analizar este tipo de cosas la diferencia
es pequeña no vas a encontrar diferencias gigantescas normalmente se van a mover todos
en 17 22 y la volatilidad así que vas a ver hay muchas diferencias y liga una cosa con la con la
otra pero trabajaremos trabajaremos una clase de todo esto trabajaremos una clase de en el
guión que tengo lo lo lo tengo apuntado tengo apuntado a hacer una clase de régimen igual que
tengo apuntado a hacer una búsqueda de ideas con códigos tengo una serie de cosas que quiero
ir haciendo pero que sí que no tengo exactamente sido cuando meterlo porque va a depender un poco
de las clases del ritmo de todo como vaya viendo yo mis sensaciones de que se va siguiendo el grupo
ir metiendo cosas más complejas antes o después pero lo veremos seguro veremos identificación
del régimen del mercado pero supongo que por ahí me vas con el santo grial no es fácil es
no es fácil y es verdad que tener el sistema perfecto que se adapta volatilidad es más fácil
al final hay que meter indicadores reglas como te he dicho este tipo en un sistema breakout en un
sistema de revés en la media digamos lo contrario no lo explico ahora pero es obvio lo contrario ahí
lo que nos interesa es momentos de volatilidad porque es cuando el mercado cuando ya hay una
explosión de volatilidad es más probable que revierta no necesariamente quiero lateral quiero
reversión problemas de identificar el punto claro que no es fácil pero la versión es más probable
la reversión vuelta es una explosión de volatilidad me acabo de revierte como aquí veis hay una
explosión es habitual pero claro no 100% de las veces vale queda buena cosa por ahí alberto
crees comentar algo de la clase de hoy que me haya olvidado que creas que sea vital de
mitad la importancia tienes micro no alberto si no si si puedes hablar puedes hablar si quieres
hablar pues nada más si hay alguna preguntita más por ahí hablen ahora o callen para siempre
bueno hasta los que bien hecho recuerdo el disco le recuerdo que podéis ir ahí al disco
preguntar tenéis aquí el canal aquel que todavía no haya entrado el disco que nos pide acceso por
email para entrar gente va entrando nuevos alumnos se van apuntando aquí está el disco de todo el
mundo y luego para los alumnos hay que pedir acceso particular porque hay unos grupos especiales de
alumnos que ahí hay algo de material ahí podéis preguntar eso solo ahí solo pueden acceder los
alumnos y para eso nos tienes que pedir acceso con el mismo email podéis preguntar ahí lo que
queráis y o bien contestamos el disco lo bien para las siguientes clases y consideramos que
la primera clase de muchas preguntas está la segunda menos por eso tampoco he dejado un espacio
final porque no había nada que responder del disco de acuerdo pues nada más familia nos vemos
el lunes que viene de acuerdo el lunes que viene desarrollaremos evaluaremos este sistema y así nos
da tiempo preparar a una otra a una otra cosa pero en general la idea que tengo es evaluar este
sistema bien evaluado y tratar de ya presentarlo y decidir qué hacemos con él si nos lo quedamos
para para la lista que vamos a ir haciendo para el final hacer un portfolio porque lógicamente el
portfolio lo iremos haciendo con sistemas y bueno este que lo damos por bueno de momento o no ya
lo veremos recordar que he dejado ahí los documentos del don chanel que no lo
he cogido aunque también lo subiremos al al discord de acuerdo hasta el lunes que viene chao gracias